une production du studio sfr bienvenue
ou sans filtre le podcast où on parle de
ce qu'on veut avec nos invités la petite
je perds ce campement dont plan quel
timing est prévisible l'écrivît écouter
à cette semaine le podcast est présenté
par notre tâche pétillant l'ap hp tout
en nous est ce que on a tous nos
podcasts en avance fait qu'on a déjà
tous les podcasts qu'on a tourné le sens
bien donc on ne le dit viendrait d'un
immeuble shebab le chef on a permis la
vallée et catherine lefebvre qui sont là
dessus à chaque fois qu'on me confie le
podcast on le met là dessus au stock est
tournée sinon le après avoir fait cette
introduction là on va enregistrer un
podcast ensemble qui va être exclusif
aux membres et ruelles parce que
d'hommes vont nous raconter en certaines
parties sont son voyage à cuba
[Rires]
tellement pas grand chose à raconter
mais trois gardes
ça va être bon on va mettre le lien à
fond notre patrie tuân dans la
description de ce podcast loppsi aussi
la meilleure façon de nous a encouragés
pour trois pièces par mois vous avez
accès à tous
sinon cette semaine cette maladresse
laurent turcot qui est un historien prof
provisoire merci d'être hors d'iran et
hommes de médias et vulgarisateur
scientifique des fins scientifiques
historiques qui qui fait des chroniques
le décret n'est que longtemps c'est le
bonjour maintenant et on l'entend
radio-canada la radio aussi et
travailler sur un jeu vidéo assassin's
creed assassin's creed
unity qui se passe un autre jeu
d'ubisoft en fait je comprends pourquoi
la confusion avec plus de chauffards qui
se passe dans l'univers des paris du
xviiie siècle ça se trouve être sa
spécialité c'est le sujet le service
études 1,18 mg istres puis en fait mais
laurent c'est vraiment un excellent
communicateur
c'est un grand intellectuel à mon avis
c'est aussi un gars sa propre chaîne
youtube
il s'appelle l'histoire nous le dira sur
laquelle il fait pas de peine à faire
l'histoire de la poutine doit décider
soit de ceux aussi l'histoire de la
révolution française
le sujet ce paraissent pas intéressant
dont c'est toujours curieux de connaître
la provenance d origine alors c'est une
discussion que j'ai adoré ton critique
est à l'aise avec le micro que beaucoup
jaser beaucoup d'informations pacte et
la sépaq à cela beaucoup de choses à
apprendre de ce galeux moi j'essaie un
grand coup de coeur ouais ça a été un
podcast extrêmement intéressant des fois
des fois elle leur en parler il parlait
plus y avait une idée qui populeux
unique pop et la musique pop et le
choisir sur laquelle va bondir c'est
vraiment super conversation fait qu' on
espère que vous allez aimer autant que
nous participez à la discussion
écrivains des commentaires suite à l
écoute du bal à dos les seniors eux
étaient un peu importe ce que vous
écoutez vos podcasts ce soit sur youtube
sur ce volet sur balles à dos puis
toutes les autres plateformes dans le
fond peu importe où est-ce que vous avez
vos podcasts et sans plus attendre
bonne écoute bon podcast
[Musique]
fort e f
merci beaucoup d'être là d'avoir accepté
de vrais vases et c'est c'est la ja j'ai
écouté ton tête tank que tu as fait sur
assassin's creed sera s'associer sur les
jeux vidéo qui pour raconter l'histoire
puis j'étais justement en train de jouer
à assassin's creed dernièrement le guen
odyssée celui sur la grèce antique et
puis j'étais justement en train de me
dire parce qu'en plus dans dix sites
communs d'un aigle qui volent notre site
web tu peux regarder
c'est aux alentours puis ça fait à peu
près une semaine que je voulais mais
j'étais justement en train de me dire
c'est débile c'est débile ce qu'on peut
faire avec
avec les jeux vidéo puis puis c'est
exactement ce que tu parlais mexès jeu
super content qu'on peut se parler
aujourd'hui aussi ouais toi ce que tu as
travaillé surtout la cdu l'ombre j'ai
travaillé seulement sur celui sur la
révolution française parce que c'est ma
job au départ moi je suis prof à
l'université j'ai une spécialité le
faites attention vous allez voir c'est
si je suis 18e east c'est que je
spécialiste du xviiie siècle j'ai fait
ma thèse sur mer 18e puis quand ubisoft
qui est basée en partie à montréal ce
n'est pas qu'à montréal ont commencé à
penser qu'ils allaient faire un jeu sur
le pari de la révolution française ils
ont cherché des historiens qu'ils
étaient capables de parler français
certes mais aussi en anglais parce qu'il
fallait donner une formation toronto
donc ils m'ont contacté puis moi j'ai
mon domaine de spécialisation cpo
l'histoire politique c'est plutôt
l'histoire de la vie quotidienne
maintenant ça se passe dans la vie
ordinaire c'est quoi que les gens
mangent etc etc etc on ont reconstitué
le pari de 1789 ce qui est la chose la
plus intéressante je trouve dans se sont
inscrits c'est justement ce c'est de te
promener puis de voir le quotidien parce
qu'évidemment que les personnages connus
j'imagine qu'ils sont bien représentés
mais peut-être que certaines nuances
sont son pôle alors que d'un quotidien
monsieur madame tout le monde une fois
qu'on allait les faits s'est présenté
métier un des éléments mois que sur
lequel j'insiste beaucoup autant dans
tout ce que je tente hommes de
vulgarisation puis de présence
médiatique c'est que tu peux pas donné à
tout le monde l'équivalent des
connaissances qu'on va apprendre à
l'université de mossoul but en revanche
quand tu joues au jeu assassin's creed
que ce soit en grèce antique que ce soit
la renaissance italienne où que ce soit
dans la révolution française c'est cette
amorce ce feeling de décentrement tu dis
je suis plus chez nous mais il ya des
éléments qui me rattache à mon quotidien
pitié c'est ce qu'on veut faire la danse
et donne un horizon d'attenté ya plein
de gens qui tu le dis toi même tout à
leur joie ce que je dis mais ces malades
ce qu'on peut faire
métis et arrive à donner cette espèce de
d'étincelles qui va faire que les gens
vont dire j'en veux plus je veux en
savoir davantage tu crées cette espèce
de volonté pitt et sa voix contre
courant du mythe c'est ce que je dis
dans le tête toc dans le thème tant que
je commence avec trois mythes qui disait
les jeunes s'intéressent à l'histoire
les jeux vidéo c'est n'importe quoi et
c'est et cetera je démonte et ses
matelots les uns après les autres
c'est pas vrai que les jeux ne sont pas
intéressés par l'histoire simplement
c'est que s'est quant à elle dans un
court je sais pas à quoi ressemble et
vos cours d'histoire mais profite voix
qui arrive de terreur puis les profs qui
arrive qui fait juste parlé pendant
trois heures de manière très monocorde
plate dit dude
on y pu en 1970 il ya des technologies
qui nous permettent de créer cette
espèce de saisissement émotionnelle qui
fait que tu es là tu le vois tu te
promènes dans le palais de la révolution
française puis dit ok là le cpeti quand
tu dit il trois mille morts à paris tu
vois du monde se faire passer au fil de
l'épée de se voiler rue ensanglantée tu
fais en tulle vie c'est parce que j'ai
merci merci
complètement c'est fou c'est ce puits
mais je trouve ce merveilleux qu'ubisoft
a et la volonté justement d'être d'être
factuel le plus passer pitt et dede
d'être vraiment c'est parce que je dois
y investissent et engage et ils
investissent des fonds investis à
l'énergie dont on fait quelque chose
justement antilles qui concorde avec le
plus possible ses programmes acquis
vraiment que toi tu verrais secondes est
ce que c'est ça l'intérêt de nos cieux
non sauf que le jeu parce que le fils et
le petit jeu on sait ça un look hippie
oui c'est ça qui sait une teneur qui ont
pris aussi un petit peu un peu top un
peu plus tard dans la franchise parce
que de bons souvenirs pour avoir joué au
premier assassin's creed
l'accent était vraiment pas mis sur ce
ça se passait dans le temps des
templiers tu jouer le personnage
s'appelait altaïr
puis il y avait pas beaucoup d'aspects
historique tant que c'était plus ancré
dans un moment de l'histoire mais avait
pas vraiment de référence jusqu'à ce
qu'ils apprécient
je ne me rappelle plus le japon loin
dans dans mon cas la baignoire jeu vidéo
est nommé mais le deuxième
assassin's creed qui se passait dans la
renaissance italienne
ou est-ce que tu jouais n you and you
quad enseigne morricone ennio morricone
et puis pilote le moi je me rappelle le
premier le premier déclic que j'ai eu
c'est ok il faut que tu es rencontres un
inventeur et plus est passée keep le
tarif peas et michael angelo qui le
pilote audois fait qu'à partir de fois
que cet ancrage dans le réel était et
elle est dans ma tête tout ce que je
voyais après des comics et ce genre de
choc il pleurait sur leurs auteurs je te
kiffe ce steve rey puis crime c'est vrai
c'est une vraie place c'est une vraie
basilique qui est énorme qui construit
comme ça tu regarde des photos qui est
pareil comme comme quand tu étais sur le
pignon en haut avec ton assassins et
puis à ce moment j'ai craqué non là on
est on est vraiment l'heure où en est
ailleurs c'est passionnant ce que tu dis
parce que ça montre tout l'intérêt que
ubisoft à faire ce qu'ils ont compris
aussi faut pas être non plus naïfs en
pensant qu'ils se sont dit on va faire
un livre d'histoire pour tout le monde
ils se sont rendus compte que c'était
une carte marketing pour eux
l'histoire est un terrain de jeu on se
démarque avec ça puisons qui vont dire
on fait pas juste du jeu vidéo on voit
plus loin que dans le dernier assassin's
creed justement celui dont tu parles le
modem au lycée maudissez il ya le mode
discovery ou de ce fait juste de
promener se rencontrent des gens qui le
dessus lippi c'est une impression c'est
presque un google street view moins de
la grèce antique
puis même de l'egypte antique puis tu
dis ok là on a vraiment passé à la
vitesse supérieure
puis milieu de l'enseignement et je veux
pas être critique sur mon milieu je veux
l'être quand même le mais on est
vraiment en retard d'une cinquantaine
d'années c'est quand tu dis que même les
films on commence à les utiliser dans
les cours
quand je sais que ça va prendre pour que
le jeu vidéo renty depuis 2002 le jeu
vidéo engrange plus d'argent que les
films les films hollywoodiens c'est vous
dire
seule remarque parce que quand tu
regarde la télé tu sois même que les
jeux vidéo font maintenant de la pub à
la télé s'est rendu le médium par
excellence mais c'est balayer du revers
de la main par tous les grands médias ou
presque et qui sont meanstream c'est
considéré comme l'encasernement des
esprits c'est considéré comme la
crétinisation des masses et pourtant
quand tu regardes assassin's creed yole
une matière extrêmement importante
s'il y en a qui vont dire oh ça fait à
peine 20 ans que les jeux vidéo existent
chèque en 1950 que ça existe les jeux de
vidéo on parle d'une génération été
prise d'une génération mario sonic et
cetera
donc il est peut-être temps qu'on rentre
là dans dix ans il ya plus que de la
scène crétinisation c'est vrai que la
violence mais c'est pas vrai que don
fait le lien entre violence et
agressivité
souvent c'est une soupape social pour
quelque chose il faut être capable de
dépasser social normal que par exemple
dans les grands médias on parle pas des
sorties de jeux vidéo mais en même temps
si on va plus loin de la culture en
général dans les médias il y en a de
moins en moins soit une vedette roque
que je vais pas voter car c'est avec ta
blonde mais on va peut-être en parler
mais il ya un problème le saut c'est sûr
ouais il ya plein d'affaires qui me sont
venues en tête pendant que tu parlais le
comme si j'ai l'impression que cette
conversation le
tu parlais des films qu'on commence à
peine à les utiliser en histoire moi
j'ai eu deux expérience de professeur
d'histoire complètement différentes le
premier marc très belle marque on va pas
dire son nom de famille l'histoire
mahraoui oui toi étiez dans quelle ville
ok mais aussi marc était passionnant
est-ce que c'était au cégep garneau
non là on était au second échelon argent
r2 je pense le point du scolaire de qui
on avait écouté gladiator gladiator pour
j'imagine beaucoup d'imperfections
historique j'ai fait une capsule je sais
je les laissais justement la gladiature
qui était un bon que j'avais jamais
c'est magique mais on avait coûté
gladiator mais on l'avait écouté
commenté par notre profession sur des
points
historique parce que j'imagine comme qui
a beaucoup comme comme je dis n'existe
inexactitudes historiques dans gladiator
mais j'imagine aussi que beaucoup de
réussite
oui puis sur l'a10 écouteurs en
commentant sa puis je me rappelle j'ai
encore des images vivid de ces
commentaires puis de la réception à
cette oeuvre
comparé à mon autre expérience je
n'aimerais pas le professeur mais
c'était un petit peu j'imagine que tu me
cites qui je parle ou sql cas qu'on
arrivait par exemple comme usa on
faisait de notation second barbe qu'un
qu'on arrivait de notre rue
entraînement le matin et si on avait un
cours d'histoire en première période est
la sieste on s'endormait
ça s'était mal en pis et même plus une
question de sujet parce que dans ce
cours là où est-ce que c'était plus
difficile d'accès ont parlé entre autres
choses de la relation avec les avec les
premières nations
ici l'arrivée des colons en amérique ce
qui dans ma tête j'imagine pour avoir
jouer à red dead redemption qui est un
jeu de fort worth qui côtoient les
premières nations de voir l'arrivée des
colons en amérique en jeu vidéo aurait
été sans aucun doute extrêmement
intéressant et motivant
intellectuellement
alors que la version d'avoir juste un
récit même pas réussi en fait juste des
faits ouais parce que tous et à toutes
une manière de mise en récit aussi des
choses c'est ce que j'essaye de raconter
l'histoire c'est seul problème parce que
tu es en histoire tu as un grand
problème actuellement qui beaucoup d'un
problème français mais qui s'en porte
ici c'est ce qu'on appelle le roman
national à dire si on raconte l'histoire
pour donner des modèles identitaire les
grands hommes ainsi sur les grands
hommes parce que c'est souvent des
hommes c'est en france ça va être
charles de gaulle napoléon louis xiv qui
on est plus justement juste ces grands
hommes là pour dire aux petits français
vous êtes une grande nation est bien ici
ce roman national c'est l'histoire
blanche hommes - française dans le
catholique puis là quand on arrive
depuis quelques années on dit oui mais
c'est pas sur l'histoire et hull
avantages qu'ils ont pourrait-on dire
c'est qu'ils font c'est comme un récit
une épopée qui nous enveloppe qui nous
emporte qui est très émotive
plus tu dis le récit est une chose trop
importante pour le laisser entre les
mains des identitaires qui veulent
former une nation qui selon moi est
fermé on peut être inclusif en s'ouvrant
justement la différence si tu parles des
premières nations
c'est vrai que là le regard qu'on porte
depuis plusieurs années sur les
premières nations cesson un regard qui
et avilissant nous sommes les dominants
et vous nous avons gagné point final
tête qui est temps de reconsidérer sa
d'où la raison pour laquelle si on dit
l'histoire facile tous vos livres
d'histoire du liban
parce que tu as aussi d'où tu viens d'où
on part aujourd'hui t on parlera aux
rondes ont parlé de l'humour et ses
thérapies de ce qu'on pouvait dire ce
qu'on fait pas de dire on va regarder le
passé à long de ce qu'on vit plus rien
de plus présent que le passé une
vingtaine d'années continue mais il ya
une veille aurait de plus présent que
deux revenaient une vingtaine d'années
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait un
groupe qu'on appelle les homosexuels
puis on s'est dit peut-être qu'il
faudrait les considérez donc là on a on
est revenu dans l'histoire en dix ans
les revendications homosexuels et
lesbiennes elles ne sont pas neufs
éclate on repart de la rome antique pour
en arriver aujourd'hui pour dire gagne
ça existe depuis longtemps
c'est une longue lutte et aujourd'hui
nous sommes les fils et les filles de
cette lutte là pis la question qu'on se
pose c'est comment on fait pour gérer ça
c'est l'historien il va pas arriver avec
son cours en tweed avec ses patch de
cuir pour te rencontrer des trucs plein
l'historien dans ma tête c'est celui qui
va arriver pour dire gagne capote
épaules ce que vous êtes en train de vie
on l'a déjà vécu mais c'est pas parce
qu'on connaît l'histoire qu'on va savoir
quoi faire mais ça va vous enrichir puis
vous donner une perspective puis vous
ouvrir d'où les jeux vidéo
d'où les films d'où le récit qui peut
nous emporter doux l'inclusion qu'on
peut avoir des groupes sociaux qui sont
marginalisés encore aujourd'hui c'est
par les drames en national tipi
malheureusement justement aujourd'hui on
dit que me reste pas grand chose des
cours d'histoire que j'ai eus opprimant
seul honda
j'en ai juste des mémoires un peu flou
j'entendis parler des événements
marquants mais je serai pas été
expliquées août et d'écrire vraiment
puis pauvres et honnêtement je suis pas
fier de le dire mais je connais tu m'as
l'histoire je connais mal sauf québec
puis je pourrais pas quelqu'un posait
question raconte moi résume moi
l'histoire de ton pays j'arrive vraiment
beaucoup de misère à lui faire une
espèce de chamant des récits du québec
j'ai fait j'ai fait des textes avant
j'écrivais des textes pour les jeunes du
primaire puis j'essayais de
de trouver des sujets qui pouvait être
intéressant puis je me rappelle à
emmener je tombais sur la révolte des
patriotes
oui puis quand chic ans j'avais vu ah
oui c'est vrai je préfère un texte sur
ce j'en avais entendu parler au second
j'avais entendu parler quelqu'un avait
dit ces mots là dans cet ordre la
révolte des patriotes
mais c'était pas mal tout sénat je me
suis mis à lire sur la révolte des
patriotes
c'est la chose la plus fascinante c'est
digne d'un d'un film c'est hollywoodien
c'est débile mais oui pis pions t mais
ce n'est pas la voix qui racontent et
plus je l'avenir c'est que penses tu de
moi c'est non on n'est pas prêt mais
sait on dirait que une chose que je me
souviens justement c'est des figures
qu'on a transformé en héros très puis de
cancon cancon raconte l'histoire autres
comme moi aux primaires
christophe colomb c'était un rôle
c'était un aventurier c'était quelqu'un
qui est qui qui a quitté son pays pour
découvrir et puis pour trouver des
nouvelles routes pipeau pis pilotes
après ce campement réfléchir de kim et
ceux ci la lunette avec laquelle nous
raconte notre histoire mais tous
demandent à un autochtone ici ou
quelqu'un que d'un autre perspective
historique qui sauf que lens peut
nécessairement un héros pour nom c'est
comme ça qu'on a construit un passé on a
construit justement ce récit là pour se
définir nous exactement ce défi ni
beaucoup comme nation comme peuple en
fonction de ce qui nous ont amené la
douce qu'on pourrait qualifier de
fabrique des héros qui souvent on en a
besoin d'un routier le modèle ultime
c'est dollars des hommes vous connaissez
un petit peu dollard des ormeaux du ski
mais à la fin du 19e siècle et on a fait
la fin de la reine de la reine victoria
les canadiens français ce design oui on
va fêter une reine britannique fait
qu'il fallait un héros rapide on ne
trouvait un qui s'appelait dollard des
ormeaux en fait c'est un gars qui est à
moitié choqué lance un baril de poudre
sur les autochtones
le baril est revenue d'en face il y est
mort mais on s'est dit n'allons ce goal
ayant empêché les autochtones d'aller
chercher le gouverneur de callières
fixed en héros se dit oui meilleur
une vraie la dalle si ces montées en
épingle pour le buzz oui effectué le
match comme moi c'est de dire aux gens
ce qu on vous aura compté des fois un
c'est n'importe quoi
pi 2 ce que vous pensez être noir ou
blanc c'est une instit hongrie avec je
vais pas vous donner de sens je vais
vous donner la complexité des choses
parce que tu es en histoire on travaille
pas sur le passé
on travaille sur les traces du passé ce
qu'il en reste par exemple la grève de
2012 que vous avez sans doute vécu une
manière ou d'une autre dans la rue et la
rue dans 200 ans de quoi on va se
rappeler va se rappeler que gabriel
nadeau-dubois fin texte et on va
beaucoup travailler sur ce texte
si vous allez vais laisser une trace
dans un journal quelconque vous avez
publié un texte
sosa va servir mais finalement si on
veut passer à l'histoire là il faut
laisser un legs de ce qu'on ne fait et
6e l'aiglon qui va être étudié par la
suite qui d'historiens qui arrive fait
comme un policier dit bon ok moi je veux
travailler par exemple sur la révolte
des patriotes
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme personnage que
vécu ce bon papy non mais tu écris il
aussi écrit ses mémoires l'on lit ses
mémoires on dit ouais mais là lui va
raconter de sa perspective à lui faut
que je la comprends donc on appelle à la
barre un autre témoin avec finalement
c'est comme une enquête policière est en
cours
15 les histoires pour peu qu'on soit
capable de le considérer comme ça les
profs
si dans la mise en récit est aussi une
manière de le présenter comme une
enquête pis on le fait mais on devrait
le faire davantage mais ça ça fait
partie de notre job de dire il ya plus
que ce qu'on vous dit puis plus
d'intérêt que vous pensez qu'ils auront
une histoire du quai c'est plus que
c'est plus complexe parce que justement
je prends les patriotes site raconte
l'histoire de notre point de vue commun
que nous la raconte en tant qu'un des
français québécois ce torero mais selon
un autre point de vue ça peut être un
terroriste
oui vous avez vu parce que je me suis
amusé à faire une vidéo un peu parodique
avec olivier morin qui est un comédien
il personnifie stéphane bern et qui
débarque à montréal qui connaît pas du
tout l'histoire canadienne française qui
invente un petit peu puis parle des
patriotes
puis lui parle de toutes ces broutilles
et finalement ils l'interprètent comme
un go qui est un qui veut la monarchie
qui contre eux du fait que le tibet
raconté j'ai comme voulu faire l'extrême
opposé pour montrer défaut des visions
peuvent se poser mais le thé encore
aujourd'hui on est obsédé par ça quelle
est la vérité la vérité il y en a une
parce que là on aurait tort de croire
que tout est une question de point de
vue c'est pas sur cette histoire quelque
chose qui sont arrivés c'est factuel que
les frissons sont pas sains
après ce lait le sens que tu as qui est
un faire dedans après ce site où c'est
toi qui le met l'homme éveiller des
choses qui sont arrivées objectivement
on pleurait on peut raconter je prends
de manière objective plus intéressant
quand même si j'aurais aimé jeu rémy
cours d'histoire ça soit justement cette
histoire le délai d'arrivée sont à coup
ce qui est arrivé ce s'est passé sur
l'autre
mais justement on dirait qu est ce qui
manquait parma qui devait certainement
marqué un intérêt de ma part à cette
époque le puis je devais pas saisir à
l'époque mais je sais zepa l'époque
l'importance de l'histoire
pisi qui essayait personne qui dit ou
qui réussit à part comprendre l'histoire
ça sert à ce liquide
un ado qu'on était où un enfant peut
penser qu histoire ça sert à rien métier
c'est difficile aussi parce que c'est
j'arrive avec des gens dans mes cours
puis la question qu'on me pose puis même
quand je faisais des études dans
l'histoire moi j'ai fait bac maîtrise
doc post-doc cm disait à quoi ça va
servir pissos vous vous le dire mais
toute votre vie à quoi ça sert ce qui
est derrière cette question là c'est une
question très clair là est ce que tu vas
faire ta vie avec ce qu'on dit ça va
rapporter c'est quoi le salaire moyen
puis what the fuck lâcher sur cette idée
là les gens qui travaillent en sciences
humaines en général se place lui
produisent in d'historiens qui vont
ouvrir on également mais c'est un
pléthore de choses
puis leur dire à quoi ça va servir sow
c'est tout l'enjeu peter raison de le
soulever à quoi ça va servir tweet -
cave puis aussi sexy tu tues toute ta
vie tu fais une job sites étudiés pour
faire une job c'est cela qui au bout de
15 ans pitot rien fait d'autre que ça
qu'est ce que tu vas faire de ta vie
puis je sais pas moi quand j'étais au
secondaire j'avais le court éducation
chocs arrière existe cinq ans
c'est pas un court mais lyon des
ateliers de choix qui est moi ça m'avait
marqué quand j'étais au secondaire
écoute milieu des fins début des années
90 par dont il disait vous allez voir
vous votre génération savez une des
premières vous allez avoir trois quatre
métiers dans votre vie donc préparez
vous à être adaptable qui on n'arrête
pas de nous le dire ce soit y est
adaptable
préparez-vous à changer parce que votre
carrière vous évoluez mais comment tu
fais pour être adaptable et une culture
générale puis plus encore moi ce que
j'apprends mes étudiants à l'université
si je peux leur apprendre des faits je
peux leur apprendre du récit mais je
leur apprends comment travailler c'est
quand tu arrives puis je me fais souvent
interviewé par la télé ou à la radio
puis me demande de résumer quelque chose
d'ultra complexe dans un clip un tweet
finalement plaignants il ya des
collègues qui vont se balancent des
possibles petit peu pour résumer quelque
chose d'aussi compliqué en 120
caractères fin il y en a d'autres des
mauvais qu'ils vont le faire
infecte ouest fais pas ta job des
mauvais le fond je peux citer des noms
il y en a assez évident un petit peu
partout à la radio
l'ag leproux par exemple que je n'aime
pas du tout le qui lui est selon moi
très d'une fausse histoire mais tu peux
résumer les choses de manière efficace
pis on est capable de l'apprendre
simplement faux tu trompes à
l'expérience tu lis un texte est le même
un texte quand j'étais que ces 500 pages
je te donne 400 mo pour le résumé plus
le tout soit là dedans ce marché dans un
premier temps du veau mahir sauf qu'au
bout de soi sortir de l'un des jeux
capables de trouver très rapidement les
mots pour marquer le coup puis ça c'est
ultra utile dans notre société quand il
fait des pitchs dans les sociétés à
gauche à droite claude guth at on dit il
et l'ouverture speech dont on parle
beaucoup des dans l'ascenseur pitau le
temps de cinq six étages pour parler à
ton boss de ton projet c'est court un
bar où est bien plus comme matin ans à
80 secondes
plus il ya beaucoup de mes collègues qui
vont dire oui mais on tenterait de
trafic et la science en train de laisser
tomber toute la complexité de l'idée
arrêter le soc pauvres et les livres
existent les tailles existent on peut
aller profiter longuement de ces
affaires là mais si tu veux rentrer dans
l'espace public
c'est comme ça que ça marche en ce
moment c'est la game y en a beaucoup qui
veulent leurs proches à moins parce que
moi je laisse jouer la game jeu comme ok
site bein je vais rentrer dans le monde
des jeux vidéo fine on va en parler
you to find je vais y aller puis je vais
rentrer dans ce monde là je me dis si
les gens ne sont pas intéressés par à
l'histoire au québec
je le prends comme une mission je me dis
c'est de ma faute six mois qu'il n'a pas
bien expliqué puis c'est nous les jeunes
qui devront investir l'espace public
puis en même temps c'est cap autant
parce que quand je donne des conférences
ou belle soirée l'université moral dans
les société généalogique
c'est tout des têtes blanches j'adore
parler aux personnes âgées ou aux gens
de l'âge d'or sauf que sincèrement c'est
pas eux qui vont rendre utile la société
dans 20 dans 40 dans 50 ans étaient des
gens qui vont voter à droite à l'extrême
droite je peux essayer de changer leur
vote leur faire comprendre un peu qu'on
est mieux tout en gagne parce que bon de
mon côté je pense que les gens le savent
de quel bord je penche
mais en même temps si j'arrive à toucher
les jeunes c'est encore mieux
puis l'été les jeunes écoutent plus la
télé il regagne échos des podcasts vous
faites en ce moment à regarder youtube
netflix
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut que j'aille
psy la grande mission que je me donne
mais on s'entend que c'est complexe et
compliqué sa demande justement une
connaissance technique parce que bon
vous l'avez pas entendu la mairie quand
je rentrais dans le studio ici je dire
qu'il s'écoule avait quoi vous
travaillez ces travaux micro comment
vous faites t il ya une communauté qui
est en train de se créer au québec
puis il faut justement encourager ça et
les médias en ce moment sont à la
remorque de beaucoup de choses et à
chaque fois ils sortent les codes des
quotidiens as et districts travers fait
1.5 million fun mais c'est quoi la
tranche d'âge on est en train d'échapper
toute une tranche d'individus qui sont
larié ya plus de monoculture c'est la
monoculture c'était comme regarder le
bye bye tout le monde avait vu les pubs
tout le monde avait vu les mêmes
affaires aujourd'hui tu regardes le bye
bye tu fais mais de quoi il parle
elle put monoculture des algorithmes de
culture à gauche et à droite des
algorithmes de podcasts etc
donc comment tu fais pour entrer là
dedans moi je me suis dit bon bon goût
on va continuer à faire l'université ça
c'est ma job fade entend de temps en
temps des conférences mais le coeur de
ma fonction publique
ça doit être pour toucher les jeunes
c'est ce que vous faites ici justement
si c'est vraiment tellement point sur
cette affaire mais pas de casse
chaque os que j'ai ça les entrées en
direct d'une révélation qui que je
connaissais sans l'avoir sans l'avoir
matérialisée dans mon esprit de dire à
qui est-ce qu'on s'adresse c'est quoi
c'est quoi le 1.5 million qui est qu'aux
districts 31 10 quel est le 6.5 au
québec qu'il est là qu'il a piqué
larguer complètement parce puis puis
effectivement il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui écouterait le bye
bye à meilhan aucune des deux caisses
qui est abordée est juste la pub de la
mycose des ongles oui qu'est qui vous
aidera fillon comme l'avait prévu non
mais c'est ça moi j'ai moi la seule
raison pourquoi je connais cette
publication deux n'ont même pas la seule
raison que je connais cette pub là c'est
parce que quand je vais au cnes des fois
jouent à lcn puis je vois pas ce qu'il
met en scène serré et crache pas
pourquoi parce que peut même pas écouté
mais je vois un espèce dong des bengals
a cependant que je cours depuis que j'ai
envie de vomir déjà à cause de la course
mais mes mots sur la seule à faire mais
ça c'est une publicité qui est sûre la
télévision point que notre génération et
que pratique cueilleurs puisqu'elle
génération écoute juste pour oui mais
c'est troublant même temps parce que tu
vois c'est qu'on est à la veille d'un
grand robe marc et puis on fait comme
s'il n'existait poche que je veux dire
par là c'est que les producteurs en
général qui arrive aux diffuseurs les
diffuseurs radio can tva et cetera
tu as l'impression qu'ils sont
complètement coupées du monde ce que
j'entends par la coupe du monde c'est
qu'il ya une fracture générationnelle et
une fracture numérique et cette fracture
numérique qui a dans la société au
québec se voit très clairement entre
justement une culture des jeunes est une
culture des gens veut dire plus âgés et
le tu dis comment tu fais non pas pour
réduire justement cette fracture parce
que je pense que
beaucoup avec on est nés pour la plupart
avec les médias sociaux avec internet
mais comment tu fais pour investir du
contenu dans le numérique aujourd'hui
pcc j'ai fait mon article dans la presse
où je disais que sur youtube
au québec la vulgarisation scientifique
était presque nul
y'avait rien il ya viviane la langue de
syllabus qui va instruire des trucs
hallucinants qui est une française qui
migrent est ici moi j'essaie de faire
mon truc en vulgarisation historique ni
si tu regardes la vraie vulgarisation
historique deux scientifiques et
tabarouette faut que tu as cherche moi
c'était beaucoup de choses qui sont très
du divertissement pur bon grand bien
leur en face mais on serait capable de
tellement mieux
quittez vous le savez vous avez une
chaîne youtube on est capable de voir
qui est notre public puis mois sur les
61 mille abonnés que j'ai je vois que
70% de mon public étages entre 14 et 35
ans pete est ce que je propose c'est pas
nécessairement des choses qui sont
faciles sexy agréable j'ai fait 2 heures
40 sur la révolution c'est mon cours à
l'université que je fais ouais ex
manière de dire ça c'est ce qu'on salue
un essai passionnant se loger c'est en
tout cas de le rendre le plus simple
possible
oui j'ai cru savoir d'autopartage
abonnés ou de découpe qui proviennent
d'europe cinq ans pour ça c'est quand
même énorme
parce que moi je pense qu'une difficulté
au québec de fat de ce genre de conduit
le informatif pertinent mes propres au
québec c'est que on se limite beaucoup
c'est que le noyau en fait le public est
petit pour avoir des écoutes qui on
compte bon centre pour l'investir autant
d'énergie pour un si petit en guillemets
c'est intéressant parce que te dit
investir autant d'énergie je pensais que
tel à dire autant d'argent parce que ça
c'est l'autre question parce que les
gens le savent peut-être pas la maison
quand ils nous écoutent mais
l'investissement le début pour la vous
avez trois caméras qui lui qui tout un
système informatique derrière le micro
et cetera c'est pas gratuit ou est-ce
qu'on est en ce moment le rif il fallu
qu'on a sur nous mêmes et comment ça se
fait qu'il ya pas deux
subventions pour aider ce genre de
vulgarisation ou des changes qu'on
aurait comment ça se fait que toutes les
subventions qui sont organisés sont
faites pour un médium qui celui de la
télé qui ne touche qu'une génération
comment ça se fait que justement le
conseil des arts du canada n'est pas un
élément spécifique pour youtube y en a
qui vont dire oui mais youtube c'est
google en train de donner de l'argent
aux gars font encore une fois oui mais
arrêter à un moment donné la sauce et
l'éco système dans lequel nous sommes
actuellement vous pouvez leur fusée peut
créer une plateforme autres où personne
ne va aller où vous allez dans cette la
fois plateforme où les jeunes vont se
nourrir
puis vous dites bon ben on va la nourrir
avec nos productions à nous c'est toute
la question netflix encore aujourd'hui
le fameux 500 millions que le
gouvernement canadien dit on va
l'investir pour des productions
québécoises
on l'attend encore parce que dieu sait
qu'on est capables de torche esseulé
dans productions québécoises en fiction
comment ça se fait qu'on touche pas la
même manière en restauration comment ça
se fait que nos restaurants ne sont pas
considérés comme les meilleurs au monde
comment ça se fait qu'on n'arrive pas à
assumer ce côté-ci en bombe le torse en
disant fuck off on est bon on va vous le
montrer puis les jeunes vous allez voir
on torche solide qui ça je sais pas d'où
ça vient
mais c'est sûr que si on a un
gouvernement à gauche à droite qui veut
réduire ses investissements dû empêcher
les toutes les formes de diffusion
d'éducation ben là on est véritablement
côté de nos pompes et on en train de
rater quelque chose mais quand il disait
il y en a beaucoup qui viennent d'europe
c'est vrai mais moi j'ai beaucoup de
liens avec des youtuber en france c'est
comme ça que j'ai commencé leur ai
demandé c'est quoi ton matériel avec
quoi de solfège aller les voir même en
france j'ai regardé que j'ai fait c'est
vraiment pas compliqué à faire
souvent c'est le texte que tu à écrire
mais moi j'ai un prompteur gîte ou avec
des aides de l'intention métis une
dissertation que je fais à chaque fois
mais suffit qu'on leur apprennent
comment le faire
mais finalement tout le monde vos six
mètres puis sincèrement pour les gens
qui nous écoutent si vous vous dites oh
ça va être compliqué fuck off prenez
votre téléphone qui est en âge mais oui
au niveau un micro ça fait la job il ya
plein de logiciels pour faire du montage
gratuit moi ma première vidéo c'est une
catastrophe
c'est ça je suis à l'aise
j'écoutais la rétrospective de l'année
ou est-ce que tu expliques tu cette
vidéo là je crois que ta vidéo qui est
la plus écoutée
sinon je les écoute et puis tu dis
j'étais la qualité c'est pas bon la
qualité audio vidéo métiers du quoi
c'est du contenu de qualité
puis le point termine après de dire
j'imagine que l'important c'est la
qualité du contenu puis c'est 100% seul
ben j'y crois dit il y en a de plus en
plus quand même malgré tout il un des
trucs que j'écoute beaucoup si c'est
guillaume wagner qui fait son podcast
pitt et issa soit pendant deux heures et
demie qui parle c'est long deux heures
et demie
il n'y a pas un producteur pour un
diffuseur qui aurait cru à cholet puis
lui il fait pis ça marche c'est à un
moment donné on plus on va être à faire
ce plu l'écosystème va être grand plus
on va acquérir ensemble de de notoriété
pourrait-on dire comme ça plus on va
être notés se brûle comme on dit en
anglais ça j'ai beaucoup remarqué ça
parce que j'ai beaucoup étudié
l'écosystème youtube français je leur ai
demandé comment il fonctionnait ils ont
des groupes secret sur facebook qu'ils
échangent les scénarios ici parlent ils
ont compris cette notion fondamentale
que ils vont être plus forts ensemble
ils se créent même des festivals de
youtube heures pour voir comment ils
font les choses on devrait le faire ici
justement un petit cadeau vous faites
des vidéos on fait juste se rassembler
on échange on voit pis partage des
abonnés comme ça puis là dessus il faut
être absolument québécois
quand je dis c'est absolument québécois
ça veut dire qu'au québec on aime
beaucoup le consensus
on aime beaucoup avancer ensemble puis
on 900 nous suffit qu'on ne soit capable
de le mettre en pratique du point de vue
numérique puis je pense qu'on peut être
chez les français on est moins sept
fractures notamment ses drops ce qu'on a
parlé ce matin avec mes droits
j'ai vraiment l'impression que cette
fracture entre le web qui comme une
espèce d'affaires que beaucoup
comprennent pas qu'ils pas nouveau mais
nouveau pour certains pays qui comme un
espèce de ce2 de far west
versus les médias traditionnels comme la
tv la radio dans quelques dix ans tout
ça va être une seule et même affaire
probablement c'est c'est toujours
difficile de voir dans le futur ce que
ça va être parce que tu es en plus comme
historiens ont dit toi qui est utile
passé sans doute tu seras sur ce que
sera le futur des voyants d'autant plus
que tu sais pas ce qui va arriver comme
nouvelles technologies que c'est
peut-être la réalité virtuelle va
complètement transformer la chose
bref si l'intelligence artificielle qui
rentre là dedans plus métaux raison de
dire que tous souhaitent entrer est en
grande gestation c
prenons un exemple parce que l'histoire
ça aussi ça vous avez connu napster
quant à lui est arrivé aussi dit waouh
on a accès à tout que j'ai jamais eu
autant de musique qu'à l'époque de
napster mes yeux et pressa des grands
groupes qui se sont acquittés offspring
notamment qui faisait des t-shirts
napster produire y vole notre musique
ont volé notre lutte elle aussi à
l'école harcelé mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé après ça c'est qu'une
confrontation et le marché du streaming
a été intégrée par apple spotify qui
aujourd'hui des sondés plateforme
payante
on s'entend que les artistes se font
fourré mais à terme y eut la création
d'un nouvel écosystème puis en ce moment
la télé l'argent beaucoup plus important
quand même pisser identitairement
beaucoup plus fort elle a le passage est
très long à faire d'autant plus que vous
le voyez avec les différentes
plateformes que son one love qui s'en
vient il ya dix n'est plus à paul
netflix qui est là si les trucs à la
chaîne les gens capote parce qu'en
disant oui mais le sujet commence à ma
bonne et à tout ça va me coûter 100
pièces 100 piasses le sait le prix du
charisme
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils veulent c'est mon
pronostic en avant une compagnie qui va
arriver que va dire voici une boîte tout
à bonn à cette boîte là ça donne la
bonne main à toutes les sites dessus
mais il y aura en fait un service
complet jusqu'au câble
on est exactement ce qui se passe en
train dé comme quitté le bébé avec l'eau
du bain puis andreck a mené ça va
revenir pis ça va être comme un peu
disparu oui mais c'est ça c'est la télé
à la carte
mais vous avez peut-être connu vidéo non
alors vidéotron avait lancé un système
qui etais s'etait de cette boîte qui
vous nous permettait d'accéder au
contenu à la carte quand le voulait il y
avait même des jeux là dessus c'était
une catastrophe ça se termine vous y
regardez s'abaissant on pourrait voir ça
comme le début justement d'une
transformation de la télé transformation
avorter la même manière que les google
lynette google quant à sa sortie on
s'est dit waouh c'est la révolution
parce que c'était une révolution mais
peut-être que dans 20 ans on va sortir
la lentilles cornéennes google
elle va transformer tcd longue
maturation puis on a tort de croire que
ce qui arrive maintenant va
définitivement changer le monde mais ce
qu'on peut voir en revanche je vous
l'avais bien dit c'est juste une longue
longue longue maturation de la télé et
du web qui à terme je pense d'accord
avec vous vont finir par devenir très
organique
l'un avec l'autre puis on le voit on dit
- les grands les grandes chaînes
généralistes comme radio canada tva
essaie de le faire avec tous points tv
avec illico de faire une offre séparée
d'un côté puis après ça ça revient à la
télé et encore une fois c'est l'offre
séparer c'est juste la télé sur le
numérique jean paul même affaire
ils ont pas encore compris le système
qui est celui de youtube netflix
peut-être que ça va venir à terme du
moins je l'espère parce qu'on a besoin
tout à fait tout s'investit d'une
mission de partager ta passion des
connaissances puis l'histoire puis ça
devient douce et c'est pourquoi tu
c'est drôle parce que je viens d'écrire
un livre là-dessus le si tout va bien
ressortir au web à l'automne de 2020 sur
tout le processus qui m'a amené
justement à entrer dans l'espace public
puis ce modèle la mode et pas juste un
universitaire j'enseigne dans les cours
je fais des articles scientifiques des
les scientifiques sauf que je me suis
rendu
compte que 1 les livres que je
produisais très peu de gens voire
presque pas de gens j'avais l'impression
que je pouvais être socialement utiles
mais j'avais pas accès à cet espace le
pierre un moment donné il ya ubisoft qui
est arrivé dans ma vie puis là ils m'ont
proposé justement d'être consultant pour
assassin's creed unity puis le matin qui
avait été lu par quinze personnes tout
d'un coup devenu utile à des millions
non je fais ok lloyd et de game has
changed comme on dit j'ai eu un impact
marché un impact sur sur beaucoup de
monde sur comment qui voit l'histoire
sur l'intérêt speaking curiosité chez
migraine chez des millions de personnes
c'est exactement ce qu'ils plus encarté
je considère que j'ai beaucoup de chance
aussi parce que c'est les plateformes
offre une grande liberté
c'est quoi qu'on dise à chaque année à
nos clients des youtube fini on ne peut
plus la liberté créatrice nous enlève
toute la démonétisation est presque
systématique sur toutes les vidéos ou
wii sont pour en parler longtemps métier
moi je payé par le gouvernement je prof
à l'université c'est ma job pin
d'amasser répartition de charge et un
domaine qui s'appelle services à la
collectivité
puis moi dans ma tête je peux m'en
servir de ce haut fait que maintenant au
lieu de faire de la diffusion dans
l'espace public
j'en fais encore je me dis ben je le
fais par youtube puis les gens prennent
qu'ils l'utilisent comme ils le veulent
pee wee cc très obsédant pour moi mais
j'espère qu'il va en avoir d'autres
puis encore aujourd'hui la les questions
que je me pose c'est comment on fait
pour avoir plus de gens qui font de la
vulgarisation au québec
est-ce qu'il faut passer par les médiums
traditionn les médias pardon
traditionnels pour le faire ou est ce
que il faut je sais pas moi qui ai fait
faire un clash faire des insultes disent
ça fait partie quand j'ai un clash à
dire c'est faire une vidéo où tu
ramasses quelqu'un peut-il d'un bond des
idées mais en france ça marche beaucoup
ouais c'est de s'attaquer à quelqu'un je
pas sûr qu'au québec c'est laisser ses
taux dans notre adn
on n'aime pas les recommandations on
aime passer le débat c'est dommage parce
que du débat d idées jaillit la lumière
exactement des baux est important
essentiel c'est quelque chose quand je
pense qu'on doit travailler qu'on a
essayé de dans l'espace public avoir
plus d'intellectuels qui
débattre d'idées qui se confrontent
c'est très difficile puis au québec
justement c'est ici des personnes comme
toi d'intellectuels vulgarisateur sans
preuve d'avoir toutes les semaines on
adorait ça met des gens qui sont
universitaires qui sont des défunts
communicateur qui donne à travers du
tout serein un spectacle sont
intéressants qui sont engageants ça se
compte sur les doigts d'une main et ça
ça prend c'est le grand mythe de penser
on est bons enseignants sincèrement vous
seriez vous dans mon premier cours que
j'ai donné en 2006 à lui cutter
je pense pas que j'aurais aimé social
dans ce court qui m'a une certaine mes
collègues je me souviens de mes
collègues à l'uqam qui lui étaient
chargés de cours moi j'étais au bac à
l'époque qui a donné son premier cours y
arrêter son cours en prévenant parce que
d'excusés match perdu que maintenant
c'est un des meilleurs enseignants qui
existent vectis tout s'apprend la télé
aussi ça s'apprend impie plus t'en fais
plus t'es ok là il me reste cinq minutes
il me reste deux minutes il me reste une
minute au chpo nch moi quand j'arrive à
radio pia télé je me fais un papier sur
lequel j'écris
qu'est ce que je veux dire comment je
veux le dire et à qui je veux le dire et
je me dis j'ai trente secondes pour
pocher c3d la rive tout en contrôle
je prends pas le contre j'essaie de
faire passer mon message lui arrive vite
possible parce que tu le sais les
animateurs puis une maîtrise j'en ai
connu beaucoup ils sont excellents
qu'ils ont un plan qu'ils veulent donner
un endroit mais toi foot us a choisi un
moment donné j'étais invité aux yeux du
monde à metz avec christian bégin 1 puis
je me suis dit je vais à jack et mon
entrevue
j'ai décidé de ramasser le ministre
l'éducation qui était sébastien pour les
peaux pile qui venaient faire un livre
en disant que c'est important d'avoir de
l'histoire il faudrait qu'on en ait plus
lgt faux cul ou double le phoque
ministre de l'éducation qui nous dit
qu'il faut plus d'histoires pilotes du
top c'est un faux cul g10 à la télé je
savais très bien que j'allais dire ce
qui s'était préparé une piste des
scripts et dans ma tête
mettez faut tu le fasses à un moment
donné parce que si tu te prépares pas
ben tu te ramasses et si je faisais
beaucoup avec lui dans un milieu de gens
qui sont des comédiens des humoristes et
cetera puis quand tu les vois improvisé
sous indice by rien de plus préparé que
l'impro c'est la lni que vous avez
peut-être qu'une
ou même des d'improvisation c'est des
acteurs qui sont extrêmement
intelligents qui ont une finesse qui ont
une écoute mais ce travail ne lui
faisait pas tout d'un coup je m'assois
puits bop c'est la john la doxa c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça pis quand
tu vois des comédiens travaillent et
bien sûr des comédiens c'est un travail
de longue haleine je dis ça parce que je
en train de donner un cours à l'école
nationale de théâtre
je leur fais un cours d'histoire parce
qu'ils sont en train de préparer
marivaux que je vais faire tout le cours
d'histoire du xviiie siècle puis à un
moment donné je les fais lire des textes
de beaumarchais des textes de kant et
cetera
puis dès qu'ils commencent à parler de
montguyon et une incarnation pistoles ça
sort ça traverse
il ya vraiment cette puissance là qu'on
est capable d'aller chercher mais pour
répondre spécifiquement ta question
qu'il faut l'apprendre puissent
apprendre c'est moi j'ai pris des cours
de théâtre j'ai pris des cours de
diction
on est capable de le faire puis faut
être capable aussi de se réécouter je
sais pas si vous vous ré écouter vous
autant podcast mais moi quand je monte
mes vidéos je vois mes étés le juste
quelque chose devrait pas faire ça mais
vous regardez mes premières vidéos jeux
swing je suis sur la pointe des pipes
jeu swing non-stop depuis un moment
donné on me dit vous devez finir par
temps va entend voler fait que je me
suis mise sur mes talons
puis après ça le voyez je bouge beaucoup
mes mains j'essaie de me limiter jeu
fermé main comme sopi mais il faut
qu'ils soient capables de prendre la
critique faut qu'il soit capable d'amour
des gens qui faisaient ça c'est un ticos
et à béquilles il faudrait que tu évites
de faire toujours la même musique
musicalité dans ta beauté par exemple
alors aujourd'hui nous allons parler
l'oeuvre hanter cette musique ltée le
fonds soit capable pour aller vers
quelque chose de plus vrai de plus
spécial
mais travailler aussi avec tes points
d'où la raison pour laquelle la radio
c'est sans doute un des médiums les plus
agréables pour faire de la vulgarisation
parce que tu as tes notes puis tout d'un
coup tu le sais puisque l'acte voix
cherchent la date puis tu reviens la
télé c'est affreux
parce que quand j'en faisais en fait le
j'en fais moi je t'ai c'est lui bonjour
j'apprenais tout part car tu peux pas te
permettent de regarder tes notes pendant
que la caméra de films parce que tu
viens de perdre deux secondes et une
couette tout croche comme ça les gens à
regarder à quoi tu me viennent le perdre
tc en bourse mais il faut que cela
prenne ce but de la même manière quand
tu vois le réalisateur qui fait par
exemple claque il
pour bercy où il reste deux minutes deux
minutes phoque jeu j'enlève trois pages
m'en vais de suite à la conclusion qu'il
faut que tu saches avant d'entrer en
ondes combien de temps tu as tous et
toutes des trucs à un moment donné c'est
sur le sur le métier tu fais ton arpida
prend tranquillement mais dieu sait
qu'on devrait l'apprendre à l'université
je vais le faire dans les prochaines
années je tenterai de monter un cours
pour apprendre à mes étudiants en
histoire comment communiquer au public
c'est quoi un plan de converser coin
plein de contenus comment ça se passe à
la télé
comment regarder la caméra qu'à regarder
l'animateur quand insérer des images etc
puis c'est quand on est capable de leur
donner ça après ben maintenant vous êtes
capable de faire tout et n'importe quoi
sur youtube au podcast
je me rappelle je n'ai jamais entendu
autant de commentaires négatifs par
rapport aux cours de français 4 au cégep
français 4 c'est précisément c'est la
capacité de s'exprimer devant des
créatifs de créatifs puis d'avoir
capable de transmettre une des verbes
allemand puis tout le monde
tout d'abord les coups de fil aux matons
cégep mais les commentaires étaient
généralisées dans le sens de ce courrier
est inutile kim au contraire j'adorais
ce cours là aussi les cours de français
qui est qui m'a le plus marqué que je me
souviens les projets que j'ai fait que
je me souviens justement les paquets
salut que samedi serait non c'est super
important mais vite tout c'est
exceptionnel
ton désir de s'améliorer et c'est une
étape et des contradictions qui dicte de
faire ce travail là que justement
mettons le prof d'histoire connu au
secondaire qu'on havre pau lui mais où
lui et plusieurs amis avaient une bonne
diction
ils maîtrisent très bien
tout était quelque chose petit ya
quelques mois je peux être meilleur
comment je peux faire plus comment je
peux faire
quand je peux toucher plus de membres
petite fille était drivée par ce puits
ce qui fait qu'ils batterie qu'est ce
que tu fais tout ce que tu fais
aujourd'hui mais vous le faites aussi
vous autres
quand vous faites votre podcast à chaque
fois vous dit sans doute comment ça peut
être meilleur comment je peux améliorer
ça le montage est ce que je peut insérer
des images ici est ce que je pourrais
insérer de la musique c'est un work in
progress tout le temps pis un moment
donné tu dis jamais rien de fini dans la
vie c'est pas j'ai fait mon grandeurs
c'est beau maintenant je me repose sur
mes lauriers si tu te fais quelque chose
maintenant ok on s'en vont au pied
toujours un reste de ce que tu fais par
exemple tu viens de faire une quête moi
je viens de faire une capsule l'a
dernièrement sur un des plus grands faut
de l'histoire c'est que le faux journal
- adolf hitler d'éviter ces malades
il ya plein de gens qui m'ont dit oui
mais vous savez quand nos québec des
arnaqueurs qui m'envoyaient des
références j'ai fait
ok maintenant péter ya toujours ça
pousse davantage puis on mesure mal à
quel point les gens veulent en savoir
toujours plus speed mais maintenant je
vais encore dépassé je veux aller plus
loin pitié c'est le moindrement est
passionné par quelque chose puis c'est
quelque chose qui t'habite mais souvent
vouloir défoncé toutes les portes pis on
le dit pas assez aux jeunes se poursuit
et du monde qui dit on allait pas une
histoire vous avez vous pas de job faute
use pauvre être en faire une job
qu'est ce t'en sais c'est tout ce que ça
va être le monde dans 20 ans tu le sais
pas ta gueule laissez les vivre
ils veulent faire de la philo fine
l'entrepôt de l'ethnologie laissez les
vivre
c'est le seul conseil que j'avoue
données s'est testé des affaires prenez
des cours à gauche et à droite en bio
vous pourrez en matto grave prend un
coup au père tu l'âge on a une liberté à
l'université qui est hallucinante quand
vous avez passé 21 ans là vous pouvez
aller prendre n'importe quel cours en
auditeur libre
faites-le on est payé pour cela merci
aux yeux du monde qui vient voir mises
en jeu peut-être du temps libre tu fais
ce que tu veux nous moi je janssen ya du
monde qui en fait la raison pour
laquelle ip c'est que je les note pour
voir un diplôme mais au final mois jean
5 parce que je payais par l'état une
vision très collective selon moi de
l'éducation pitt est ce que je fais sur
youtube si ce qu'on appellerait
l'université populaire
il ya 30 ans c'est aller dans des
espaces par exemple de classes
laborieuses qui tuent leur raconter par
exemple l'histoire du québec
mais comme aujourd'hui c'est de plus en
plus compliqué tu dis bon ben moi je
vais toucher les jeunes qui passent par
part soit pour faire de l'éducation peut
plus communs comme un visionnement sur
ton ta vidéo de deux heures gagnées sur
la révolution française il y en a qu à b
c'est sûr que quand tu compares vous
faisiez ne suis vraiment pas seuls et
c'est vraiment pas seul objectif le mais
où est ce que je veux en venir c'est
comme il y en a alors je peux trente
mille 30 milles c'est quand même un fake
combien de cours physique
est-ce que sa princesse qui a 30 ans
étudiant dans classe qui écoutent un
cours magistral
puis on s'entend que c'est loin tout
comme ashish rice et ses dynamiques
il ya des images ça prend 1000 qu il
faut donner mille fois j'avais sur le
mais c'est si énorme faut donner mille
fois un cours sur la révolution
française pour atteindre autant de monde
que tu as atteint avec ton vidéo pitié
là on peut dire ouais mais là le taux de
rétention diminue après les problèmes de
droit mais dans un cours magistral le
taux de radiation diminue aussi après
les premières rumeurs sur facebook c'est
qu'ils restent
sa passion c'est voyons se pose je
n'avais jamais pensé non mais c'est
massif moi c'est ce qui c'est ça qui me
met pas parce que plus je dire non tu te
poses pas les codes des coûts de
certaines routes où certains youtuber
rouillou buzz qui qui parle d'eux
leur relation amoureuse du passé
l'espace que c'est pas du tout seul
produit tout ce qu'on me dit est ce que
je demande à des spécialistes web qu'est
ce que je devrais faire pour que ça
marche plus pire mais kenzy bat c'est
très simple tu parle de toi j'ai fait
bien là ça se passera juste pour non
parce que je veux pas intégré le mois ou
simplement ça doit être une la
vulgarisation historique de base mais
entre commercy j'avais moi je joue déjà
très bien les codes du médian qui eut
tout bleu stadiers reprend des des
sujets et y tonton vie d'état vidéo sur
m
le voyons les la terre plein
non non c'est un excellent exemple mais
mais c'était pas sur le poids la wii
serait en rien les créations de la
société cherche à utiliser un thème qui
était trendy surtout un petit peu avant
le mes poils après ce tir c'est quelque
chose qui trendy sur youtube fait que si
c'est un code mais tulameen avec un
raisonnement qui complètement ailleurs
que ce qu'on entend habituellement c'est
la région d'où ça vient en plus une fois
après avoir été sur cette vidéo là on
comprend beaucoup mieux le mouvement
mais poids justement le mouvement de
réappropriation
du corps de la femme on est moins dans
le jugement on est beaucoup moins dans
le jugement puis on comprend beaucoup
mieux pourquoi c'est important de mettre
de l'avant comme un réel enjeu et parce
que parce que tu donne des exemples
clairs puis le parrain de cette vidéo le
directement la méthadone des exemplaires
de textes qui ont été écrits de voici
pourquoi les femmes se raser ou s'épiler
à ce moment là pour être placé une corde
je me rappelle plus beau tout doucement
nous dire le messin courte dingo un
homme dit la fonction principale la
femme c'est comme d'être de pleurs dans
les délires à bhl est désirable donc
d'être douce le bois empêche empêche sa
fonction principale louis xv est une
sorte de violence symbolique sur le
corps de la femme - est imposée par
l'homme pour répondre un désir celui de
l'homme de le satisfaire effectué le
voit que finalement la femme s'était
hissé jusqu'au moyen âge moyen na waie
ces cas patent mais je dirais que moi
aussi beaucoup de soucis aux jo comme ça
à chaque fois que je regarde quelque
chose me dit ah il s'écroule autour de
cette affaire maintenant mais c'est tout
le temps effectué dernièrement ses
crottes de fromage
ça vient avec le chef mais c'est ce qui
est passionnant d'histoire parce que
justement mais on a parlé justement je
serai prêt avant de commencer si des
phénomènes qui nous apparaissent comme
chaud ou de l'heure ou nouveaux ont
toutes une histoire puis la plupart
d'abou diaby on citait l'exemple des
états toul avec l'article de denise
bombardier
elle est à tous ces points nouveau
phénomène jeunes à l'envers jeter les
premiers à toucher c'est pas ça remonte
à quand peut-être que tu dis cinq mille
ans mais on a trouvé une momie qui
avaient été prises dans la glace qui
date d'il ya 5000 ans que des têtes ou
sur elle fait qu'on sait pas si c'est un
tatoo de la coupole l'acupuncture
mais même les momies égyptiennes on
retrouve des tatous même temps en
amérique du sud les premières nations il
y en avait
c'est des cultures j'ai quitté à tout et
je pense météorite
c'est super important c'est ça date pas
d'hier après nous ramène mais comme tout
ça tellement intéressant de mettre les
choses dans leur contexte puis on dirait
que ça ça rassure quelque sorte où ça ça
peut nous des pompes et mieux éviter de
faire des jugements rapides tient un
chroniqueur dans un journal de montréal
pour ne pas le citer jean martin lui
fait des raccourcis et le mariage ou
vendent en notre possession n'est pas
défendre non mais c'est l'incarnation
parfaite de tout ce que tu veux pas dans
la société
oui mais c'est vrai c'est qu'il fait un
jugement par tant de lui indépendamment
de la réalité ou d'un contexte du dit
oui mais c'est de la malhonnêteté
intellectuelle pourtant si une des
personnes les plus lus au québec foetus
effectué dit comment tu fais pour te
poser des gens comme ça est ce que tu le
critique p non tu vas devenir une cible
facile
faites moi ce que je me suis dit je vais
éduquer à ma manière ou est-ce que les
gens quand ils vont travailler justement
sur l'histoire de mes poils plus etc
richard martineau il écrit des horreurs
là dessus dit il ou non seulement teinté
d'un patate mais ce que tu dis est faux
- finale qui ceci est un mensonge point
final
c'est ça que je veux faire des armes et
des consciences mais développer cet
esprit de doute c'est possible c'est
possible que sorti la fameuse hongrie ce
dont je parle est là c'est quand tu
arrives sur un sujet si tu incapacité à
dire moche pour ou contre
c'est peut-être que tu n'y a pas assez
réfléchi mois tous les sujets que l'on
me présente je veux dire ok je vais
écouter mais la vérité comme tel est
possible c'est rarement scène dans notre
société pied aujourd'hui on veut des
clips je le disais tout à l'heure ben
moi je rentre dans ce milieu-là des
liquides et des clips
sauf que dans les clips qui peut
apporter une nuance 9 je peux dire c'est
plus compliqué que ça mais ce qu'on
pourrait était toujours une manière de
le faire mais encore une fois faut que
telle expérience des médias pour soit
rompue à l'expérience puisque vous le
savez en plus on en fait plus on devient
bon puis plus on fait des rares plus on
est capable de se
travailler c'est alors le plus fou être
capable de les voir aussi cote si je
regarde tout ce que j'ai dit à la radio
à la télé j'en ai fait j'en ai dit des
niaiseries pis c'est parce que je le
sais que je fais attention puisque je m'
amende
il ya des gens qui m'écrivent en hausse
que vous avez dit aujourd'hui il faut
avez-vous tel truc tel truc fait
d'écouter pardon je les ai pas vus et
faire amende honorable je sais pas quel
char martineau quand il est grand temps
dotée d'un patate ce que tu dis il faut
venir écouter
en effet je me suis trompé c'est ça la
différence entre un esprit scientifique
puis ou de l'opinion des gens vont
s'exprimer sur des feelings vous êtes un
scientifique qui est réellement capable
de mettre un égo de côté et est heureux
de se tromper si ça peut le rapprocher
de la vérité et parce que la laquette
cpo avoir raison gagner des baux quoi
que ce soit c'est la recherche de vérité
mais si tu t'es trompé plus tard en
compte peu différemment d'honorables
petit rapport à la vérité ou si ton
collègue c'est tout public quelque chose
puis ton collègue publie quelque chose
d'autre qui répond à ce mets tu te rends
compte que c'est lui qui a raison
ben fahd la méthode scientifique a
approuvé paix devra approcher la vérité
trépy la science aujourd'hui à pas
réponse à tout non sauf que c'est
souvent la réponse à moins faux secondes
puis il ya un élément tunisie qui est
tous très important c'est dans l'espace
en général même dans l'espace privé
on n'a pas beaucoup de moments où on
peut changer d'opinion sur quelque chose
s'est il ya plusieurs personnes dans mon
entourage avec qui je discute de choses
en disant mon dépôt fait là dessus je
sais pas ce que j'en pense à eux mêmes
tarifs avec une idée tu la deep space et
dans men in the ce que je viens de dire
mais être capable de dire écoute
l'histoire de l'appropriation culturelle
jeter un petit peu remonté en voyons
c'est plus compliqué que j'en ai
beaucoup parlé avec une de mes amies
manal driss et qui me disait à dire non
a dit c'est comme si on racontait
l'histoire des noirs mais c'est les
blancs qu'il racontait jouer mais tu
sais en histoire on essaie d'objectiver
notre subjectivité puis si j'étais
arrivé avec mes affaires on sait pas
confrontés mais on a comme pour trouver
un terrain d'entente non plus mais c'est
comme une manière de dire je sais pas si
mon idée est bonne je veux la tester
avec toi tu n'es tu d'accord avec ceux
qui m'aiment tout
quand sur le deed fait excuses moche je
viens de le dire puis j'y crois pour je
crois vraiment première dix ans des fois
la parole révèle le sens pour le bon
comme pour le mauvais mecs pour ça que
c'est bon tu disais tout à l'heure le
cours de français 4 où on arrive qu'il
faut exprimer nos idées
c'est très difficile d'arriver devant
tout le monde parce que ça sous-entend
qu'il faut que tout soit fini
dans ta pensée mouche désolé mais penser
n'est jamais fini si on dit ça alors
c'est un work in progress
puis faut se laisser cet espace est ce
que vous faites ici justement l'espace
de longs moments discussions parce que
quand tu peux juste des petits trucs de
dix minutes leur moi je vais arriver
avec des idées qui sont ultra travail
est bien fait presque fini mais après
une heure la belle tu rentres dans le
territoire où je sais pas trop puisqu'il
fait que pour ce que je déteste richard
martineau parce que moi je me demande
aussi une opinion tranchée sur tout et
tu fous trois crises jeu même pas sûrs
d'avoir une opinion tranchée sur une
seule chose dans ma vie mais ouais c'est
ça pis je change de sujet passe quelque
chose que je pense depuis tantôt t on
parlait justement l'utilité dé
l'histoire bien quoi ça sert
pourquoi tu fais ça j'ai l'impression
que 6 enfin d'analogies avec mettons une
piste matmar être aussi si je me trompe
ce n'était pas d'accord avec moi mais
j'ai l'impression que l'histoire c'est
aussi a dit m je ramène à une vie
humaine suspect nérin sim et ont
toujours un pouvoir puis je me brûle je
fais et ça c'est chaud jus mais brûle
quand je fais ce je le ferai pas j'ai
appris quelque chose par l'expérience de
l'histoire c'est tout un espèce de dents
magazine masculin espèce de d'événements
sont arrivés collectivement propre ici
on l'histoire on en a la mémoire de tous
mais on le sait qui est un peu sa star
rond de poêle font attention à ceux ci
sont lavés aux cuvées aucune mémoire
d'événements mettons l'événement les
plus horribles de l'humanité deuxième
guerre mondiale
si vous n'avez aucune trace mémoire de
ceux il y aurait plus de chances que ça
arrive on n'aurait pas on ne répare des
dérives métier on va prendre un exemple
et précis celui de john grisham au
pouvoir on a fait le parallèle avec 1933
la montée en voit dans la logique là je
déteste cette comparaison pour une
raison très simple c'est que ça a réduit
notre réalité de 2016
à l'époque quand il était porté au
pouvoir ou de 2020 aujourd'hui à quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre de voici
comment ça va aller
on le sait pas quelle base ça valait et
d'autant plus dans les premiers mois du
la présidence dans notre chambre il a
fermé les frontières à certains pays et
là les gens ont dit voilà c'est la
preuve avancée les juifs
maintenant c'est rendu les pays
d'afrique etc c'est comme non si c'est
pas comme ça que vous on doit envisager
l'histoire c'est pas un appel de pied de
hitler versus crom parce que si vous
faites ça vous allez trafic et le
personnage de chambre qui beaucoup plus
complexe que ce qu'on pourrait croire et
il ya des gens qui disent est un con je
suis pas du tout de son côté là je pense
que c'est évident depuis tout à l'heure
mais en revanche à le balayer du revers
de la main d'instinct qu'on vous laissez
tomber toutes formes d'interprétation
normal que vous pouvez avoir un écran
vert ce personnage là et de s'y opposer
intelligemment quand vous dites à
quelqu'un tu es un christ de caves
il y aura pas de discussion mais quand
au contraire vous essayez de faire une
espèce de aïkido intellectuelle de m les
six confrontations
et oui comme dans le germain d'astérix
le gaulois les douze travaux pardon mais
c'est ça donc l'appel de pied de 1933 je
le trouve dangereux parce que justement
c'est un raccourci et son ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un prêt-à-penser sont m
sow dans la société les prêt-à-penser si
on revient sur la grève de 2012
un des prêt-à-penser kim kim horrifié
ses îles photosphère sa part où on doit
tous se serrer la ceinture
fuck you fuck you ça rien à voir avec se
serrer la ceinture
toi tu considères que l'on doit limiter
l'éducation ou augmenter les frais de
scolarité parce qu'on doit tout faire sa
part fo ku des grandes entreprises qui
ne peut que très peu d'impôts qui ont
des paradis fiscaux qui ont des
parachutes dorés à n'en plus finir
toi tu considères que la justice sociale
doit être limitée à tout ce b
tabarouette ils vont payer en mode
des gens l'oeuvre de jean levé oui puis
de taper sur les gens qui n'ont pas
d'argent ou qui sont marginalisés la
même manière comme quand guy nantel a
fait son spectacle qui s'attaquait aux
gens qui étaient marginalisés mais c'est
odieux c'est vraiment odieux puis celles
et tous les humoristes qui au lieu de
s'attaquer un pouvoir qui domine
s'attaque à ceux qui ont pas socialement
de place dans la société
je trouve ça très difficile aujourd'hui
parce que l'humoriste d'une capacité
justement de montrer les travers de la
société tessi le fou du roi qui était
capable d'inverser la société pour dire
l'ordre social sur le renverse regardez
à quel point c'est ridicule
aujourd'hui tu as l'impression qu' il ya
un copinage entre le pouvoir et les
humoristes ou encore les humoristes
déleste je délaisse justement la
politique pour aller vers le menu fretin
était le petit truc facile qui fait rire
mais où il manque de réflexion pis c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi que les jeux
j'avais quelques projets avec guillaume
bagdad guillaume je laime beaucoup
justement parce que y'a rien justement
renverser cette logique là ils essayent
de pas joué du tout la game 2 je vais
dans les shows de variétés etc
il fait pas de quiz rien bayeux
justement cette capacité de dire bon ben
moi je me pose justement à tout ça et je
trouve qu'en ce moment on en parlait en
ronde
on est dans une république d'humoriste
il faut absolument qu'il ya une
humoriste est partout tout le temps
qu'ils fassent rire puis quand j'ai
regardé vous avez peut-être regarder la
fureur vous avez peut-être paulette et
les organes mais c'est assez drôle parce
qu'il y avait deux équipes
il aurait peut-être regarder mais très
important de comprendre la culture de
son désir de son pays de sa province
me morice est intéressant les vieux
c'était des comédiens des animateurs
puis les jeunes étaient juste des
humoristes si au delà des humoristes
point de salut on demande aux humoristes
de ce prêt de se prononcer sur des
sujets qu'ils ne maîtrisent pas avec
lesquels eux mêmes sont pas à l'aise
puis les lions ont annoncé qu'ils
allaient faire la suite de la fura puis
on dit on va prendre des humoristes ou
des gens qui sont drôles
pourquoi belo venir c'est pas la
fonction de la fureur d'éduquer les gens
mais c'est parce que il ya d'autres gens
autre que les humoristes qui sont
capables d'être efficaces dans l'espace
public
au delà de tout ça puis j'ai toujours
peur de voir un domaine où une personne
qui commet sa maîtrise
et pendant ce temps tous les sujets pour
l'aider puis j'ai peur qu'on fasse d'un
humoriste richard martineau en puissance
qui va donner son avis sur tout et lui
même et pas à l'aise quand je dis lui ça
peut être elle aussi parce que autant
des femmes que des hommes dansent minul
puis trouve ça dangereux ayant un très
beau livre que je vous invite à lire là
dessus et bin hammam en ma chaîne
youtube c'est mathieu bélie s'appelle
bienvenu dans le pays de la vie
ordinaire et raconte justement quel
point au québec on a besoin de se
rassurer en ne parlant de rien en
faisant des choses qui ne sont au fond
aucune fonction symbole et quelle
qu'elle soit puis lui dit aujourd'hui
l'humoriste s'est véritablement le lard
ou au froid puisque celui qui domine
tout quitter la question qu'on peut se
poser est ce que c'est normal dans notre
société est ce qu'on devrait pas
entendre le sais ce que tu disais tout à
l'heure plus d'intellectuels puis moi je
me dis si on n'est pas plus présent là
c'est de notre faute
puis faut être présent voir arriver si
toutes mes collègues qui pense plus au
stade
c'est un autre domaine que tout ce que
je fais c'est inutile puis je suis en
train de faire des la vulgarité disons
le comme ça ben je leur dis ben non
c'est vous qui êtes entraînement quel
bateau parce qu'on entraînement qui est
une génération puis être dans l'espace
public on peut attendre autre chose que
du simple divertissement
je pense qu'on est capable de le faire
au québec parce qu'on le fait il ya
quelques années on le fait un petit peu
dans les réseaux comme ce qu'on est en
train de faire actuellement c'est pas
normal qu'ils aient pas au hockey autant
qu'ils aient pas autant de diffusion que
ce qu'on devrait avoir exigé
j'entendis couple je trouve que samuel
morais une position dans une drôle de
position parce que critique d'un côté
l'humoriste qui va juste vouloir faire
rire pour vraiment s'impliquer
socialement mais d'un autre côté si le
maurice propositions on va dire ben
c'est pas son domaine c'est pas son
travail prend position ce quelque chose
qui connaît pas donc les listes robin
pupponi l'association perdure dans tu as
raison c'est un perdant perdant
oui mon direct on dirait que j'ai
quasiment plus j'ai appris ce qui se
voit plus un humoriste qui veut dire moi
mon but c'est de faire rire mon but
c'est d'être drôle c'est de faire passer
un bon moment
puis je vois pas prétendre être un
expert dans quoi que ce soit il faut
laisser les experts à des experts dans
dix ans on est d'accord sauf que les
experts ou sont ils si à force tu
essaies commun
c'est comme une contamination mais sans
méchanceté bien sûr c'est qu'à un moment
donné quand un humoriste
ils sont tous là puis laisse place à
personne c'est qu'à un moment donné il
faut juste retrouver une juste part
parce que l'île maurice vont toujours
être au québec
d'ailleurs j'ai fait une vidéo sur
l'histoire de l'humour au québec en deux
parties c'est pas neuf le thé d'elsa fin
du xviiie siècle
tu avais des humoristes des humoristes
d'un génie remarquable puis on en a
encore aujourd'hui tu les écoutes tu dis
mais mon dieu c'est de l'art comme tel
en revanche là où je me pose puis je
trouve qu'on est peut-être on va
peut-être un peu trop loin c'est que si
on n'a pas d'humoristes le show va être
mauvais si un moment donné tu entendais
à la radio un humoriste qui commente la
campagne politique se fait il ya passé
expert politique pour le faire on avait
besoin d'une joke
absolument c'est vrai tu as raison il
faut on a besoin de rire c'est utile
mais de là à ce que tous les aspects de
la vie est un humoriste ou est une jeune
derrière nécessaire pis les producteurs
ou les diffuseurs ont dit oui mais le
monde aime sa femme
c'est sûr qu'ils aiment ça mais
avez-vous aussi autre chose peine que
vous pourriez aller chercher un autre
public est que vous allez développer
autre chose c'est on dit souvent en
économie s mes potes des oeufs dans le
même panier puis le je pense qu'on mette
tous les oeufs dans le même panier
peut-être qu'il va avoir un retour de
balancier mais témoin ce que j'essaie de
faire de mon compte en disant il ya des
humoristes mais nous aussi on est là et
nous voir si ça se trouve plus vous
allez venir nous voir plus vous allez
vouloir le voir ailleurs sauf que le
ailleurs ça se repose sur les médias
traditionnels savons juste à être sur
les réseaux sociaux ou encore sur les
plateformes de diffusion numérique
métier c'est quand ma porte je dire la
faute si faute il ya de l'humoriste
n'était pas trop de place il ya un
appétit pour soigner dame en bourse et
les gens en demandent les gens aiment is
more et sur les gens se déplacent pour
les shows ça ne m'a dit qu'ici quoi
l'espèce des deux soit juste milieu où
c'est ici qu'est comment complice
canaliser les le peuple québécois qui
fait qu'on a autant besoin d'humoristes
et de rires à ce point là est peut-être
quelque chose qui se cache à quelque
part là dedans
puis effectivement mois les segments
à la radio des tops en tout cas ne pas
la nommer où on a dix maurice qui se
prononce sur l'actualité ces premiers
segments préféré justement parce que je
trouve je trouve chenilles en train de
rire aux éclats
ni en train d'apprendre vraiment quelque
chose je préférerai toujours chantal
hébert c'est quand chantal hébert vous
la connaissez un peu oui
analyse politique quand la rive cac
paraître donne le la titulaire ou à
l'école c'est elle que je veux pour me
parler de politique canadienne ou
québécoise parce que hélas les échos de
la chambre c'est pas un sentiment non
plus tu sais comme c'est pas de chantal
hébert qu'on va parler alors rien à
vendre
chantal hébert avant l opow de shoah fin
c'est ça que j'aime des analystes
politiques mais encore une fois que
servier ce qu'on a dit faut être capable
de bien passer son message
gérald fillion par exemple la radio can
du point de vue économique et je
comprends tout je vraiment intelligent
mais c'est la job du communicateur
justement d'être rendre les choses le
plus simplement possible
puis il coûte on est capable de faire
sur tous les domaines
puis l'humoriste va toujours exister
quoi qu'on fasse quoi qu'on dise puis
c'est très bien comme ça parce qu'il
faut qu'ils aient une diversité de
cultures en revanche de l'ass qui
prennent toute la place
le chemin bémol puis comme tu disais
tout à l'heure le juste milieu où est ce
qui va arriver mais c'est peut-être en
replaçant un peu l'écart pied en se
disant prêt qui ne trouve peut-être
compte aller trop loin
puis peut-être que il faut amener
d'autres gens dans l'espace public pour
nous parler de choses pour parlons de
l'humour parce que dit quelque chose
tantôt qui m'a vraiment intéressé parce
que dernièrement
sans rentrer trop dans les détails et
je travaille sur une campagne dont jean
dragon je faisais des recherches sur les
fous du roi
oui les fous du roi corrigez moi si je
me trompe ça se peut que ce soit pas du
tout historiquement à cueillette mais l
épouse du roi était parmi les seuls qui
pouvaient un peu rire du roi périr du
pouvoir en utilisant l'humour pour le
faire pourtant doute te dit quelque
chose qui était vraiment intéressant
pire que maintenant il ya beaucoup de
blagues sont dirigés pauvres non pas
vers le pouvoir mais vers les gens
marginalisés on pense évidemment à toute
la saga de mike ward
qu'est ce qui fait que maintenant le
drôle peut être dirigé vers les les gens
en marge comme ankama eu ce changement
là comment c'est arrivé
c'est super parce que pour le mettre le
fou du roi initialement ne veut pas
décemment rire de la plèbe à ce qui ce
n'est pas un sujet qui se portaient à
rien quand même beaucoup de la plèbe
c'est quand tu regardes certaines des
comédies de molière même dandois juin
mais on voit deux personnages du peuple
qui molière se fout d'eux je n'en plus
finir mais en revanche 6e il veut aussi
s'attaquer à tous les puissantes il est
dans les femmes savantes le bourgeois
gentilhomme et ou encore dans le
tartuffe si vous avez jamais lu du
molière josaine tire remarquablement
bien écrit j'ai lu beaucoup de molière
mais veut vraiment long mais ça vaut la
peine en pis en plus le ils vont jouer
le malade imaginaire ou rideau vert
votre est loin aller le voir vous allez
voir le terrain c'est tellement pas pour
moi le théâtre n'existe pas aux yeux des
pièces qui sont faites pour vous plus
beau théâtre à montréal puis même au
québec puis ça vaut la peine
c'est vraiment intéressant métier pour
répondre à ta question c'est super
intéressant s'il y aurait un livre à
écrire là dessus quand est ce que le
changement
justement due aux attaques du pouvoir
aux grands du pouvoir à ceux qui sont
marginalisés
premièrement ce qu'on pourrait dire
c'est que c'est sûr que les gens qui
sont marginalisés vont avoir moins d
espace pour se défendre
donc il va avoir une espèce de faciliter
ou est-ce que tu as repos le retour de
de massue disons le comme ceci tu
t'attaques par exemple à françois
legault mais de manière très très très
agressive lui votre procès en
diffamation point final pleurs les gens
mondiale est ce que c'est une limite de
l'humour est ce que il ya un cadre qu'on
devait mettre c'est comme un quad le dis
aux oliviers et de la joke on devrait la
considérer sous deux aspects le contexte
pis l'intention d'y passer plus
compliqué que ça le s'impliquent tout un
point de vue légal qui celui de la
charte des droits et libertés mais aussi
de la diffamation envers quelqu'un puis
d'une forme d'acharnement on peut tout à
fait dire que l'humour doit avoir une
liberté de tout dire je pense qu'on doit
être capable de tout l'exemple parfait
c'est charlie hebdo
charlie hebdo qui disait écoutez si on
n'utilise pas la liberté d'expression on
va la perdre pied y allait dans
l'extrême puis des fautes 10 et grinçant
c'est dur mais toute la question de dire
est ce qu'on doit s'attaquer aux
marginaux aux puissants charlie hebdo
avait une plus grande tendance à
s'attaquer à ce qui avait un pouvoir
réel ou symbolique
ici je pense que c'est difficile de dire
ici mais quand on s'attaque à des gens
qui sont pas capables de se défendre ou
qui ont pas d espace social ou des
espaces publics j'ai fait était de rôle
d'adjoint
sauf que est-ce que l'effet que ça peut
avoir va être bénéfique ou mauvais pied
t il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on
pourrait dire la première fois que j'ai
beaucoup aimé écouter ce que dit je
l'écoutais au podcast de wagner
j'écoutais à gauche à droite je
comprends son poing puis je comprends
pourquoi ils vont encore suprême puis
c'est tout à fait légitime de sa part
en revanche c'est vrai que quand tu
laisses aller des choses qui peuvent
être agressive et qui sont en limite de
la diffamation du tibet peut-être que je
pourrais juste l'enlever ou ne pas aller
là parce que au québec au canada on
réalise pas à quel point une capacité de
dire tout ce qu'on veut c'est que judith
lussier qui fait un très beau les qui
s'appelle on peut plus rien dire ou es
ce cas démontre exactement l'inversé on
ne jamais pu dire autant de choses
aujourd'hui
la seule chose c'est que il ya des gens
que si vous dites ce que vous voulez si
vous êtes de la main et vous allez vous
faire attaquer donc on a une liberté
extrêmement grande au québec qu on
mesure mal parce que justement quand il
ya ces petits accrocs ont dit ça y est
on peut plus rien dire
c'est la fin de notre société c'est plus
compliqué c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure
longtemps train de faire une grosse zone
grise en disant c'est ni pour ni contre
bien au contraire mais j'aimerais avoir
un style du maupiti ont dit soit
l'humour il y en a pour tous les goûts
c'est comme sa palette moi j'aimerais un
style du mot qui plus grinçant vers les
politiques plus grinçant vers ceux qui
ont le pouvoir
c'est avec ce qui s'est passé en quête
le lino saputo semble un bon show
d'humour
c'est un show d'humour avec pkp sa
serait pas un show d'humour à pascal ça
sert à rien tu mets ton genre et du fort
c'est le fou du roi
sauf que de la façon avec laquelle il
fait c'est vraiment loin d'être aussi
agressif tentant pas de job sur jérémy
gabriel et nous t'en as pas de job comme
celle qui était fait sur jérémy gabriel
anvar n'importe qui qui est en position
de pouvoir une blague aussi agressé
justement l'exemple de ce si beau si
mike ward aurait jamais fait cette
blague le je retire ce que j'ai - oui je
ferai jamais une blague aussi agressive
que celle en barges et rémy gabriel que
celle que mme encore la fête envers
jérémy morel moi je ferais jamais sur
envers pierre karl péladeau parce qu'il
débarquerait chez nous avec toute la
force qui me ruine ray mais ce que la
job ce serait drôle parce que aussi
drôle que lojack parce qu'à suivre la
logique de mike ward l'intention et le
contexte le dédouanerait de toute forme
de critique ou d'attac
mais c'est là que tu vois que c'est
intéressant ce que tu dis si on prend le
contexte comme tel lieu le contexte du
pouvoir et d'où la raison pour laquelle
certains humoristes vont plutôt
s'attaquer à des gens qui n'ont pas de
pouvoir que les gens du pouvoir dit guy
nantel qui s'est attaqué à l'espagne est
allé ce paquet pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent pas c'est celle qui avait 10
ans
fais violer par gerry sklavounos ancien
député libéral et ben tu dis est ce que
tu as vraiment besoin d'aller là où tu
vraiment besoin de s'attaquer à des gens
qui sont sous le tapis qui ont pas de
place que qu'on ne crois pas tu veux
vraiment écrasé du monde comme ça dit il
quand je disais tout à l'heure l'effet
yo ce que tu veux dire ce que les gens
comprennent
puis la différence entre les deux c'est
si toi ce que tu veux dire c'est on peut
tout dire dans notre société on peut
même rêver d'un handicapé mais ce que
les gens comprennent seuil et il est
faux qui meurent wells et à job de dire
sponsors parce que je les ai je voulais
dire ici au québec on est facile là
dessus pour s'excuser puis on est bon
pour le faire puis les gens comprennent
entendre ses excuses et oui on est sans
cesse les pommes masturber dans un parc
quelques années plus en place et d
attendre braxis mais si je peux apporter
une nuance
vous êtes a fait entrer mettons nuances
au sans fil et guy nantel sais que tu
m'accordes fait cette blague le cert
s'est fait des blagues et de foi qui
flirte avec les racismes qui flirte
alexis avec se mêler cta testostérone
derrière mike comme des clips de
testostérone est elle sortie du tos
intensivement il pourrait pas animé les
oscars au sujet avec les mets mais c'est
ça c'est mais je pense que je j'ai
vraiment l'impression puis je pense que
mon flair de deuxième degré thaci affiné
a aiguisé pour savoir que
personnellement ma quad absolument rien
contre meeting ou qui est ou qui était
capitaine jack et raciste c'est plus je
pense c'est vraiment plus des racistes
qui rit que des minorités comprend du
puits mauger
j'ai l'impression que je décèle je parle
je pense que je capte bien sûr
l'intention après ce guy nantel qui
s'attaquent je mets des guillemets m
on peut les remettre ou non à alès
paquet durant l'impression que son
intention c'est attaques y aller ce
paquet comprend ce que je disais ouais
je comprends tout à fait je pense qu'ils
étaient il y en a un que son message son
intervention c'est sûr puis l'autre que
c'est possible mais il y aussi t qu'est
ce que ça a comme effet soit c'est quoi
le ce que les gens retiennent pythie
quand tu vois la violence que subit
jérémy gabriel depuis qu exane étudié
man et personne ne devrait subir sopi
quand tu regardes ses chemins parallèles
safia nolin qui se ramasse des
commentaires outranciers sur son
physique du 10 mai ça n'a pas de bon
sens on peut pas aller là il faut un
moment donné
encapsulé ça pour empêcher que cette
violence sous et un écho dans l'espace
public
puis mike ward est un personnage public
et il le sait très bien il connaît sa
position et il le sait qu'il ya une une
fonction qui doit lui donner ou du moins
empêcher ce genre de dérives il aurait
pu le faire
il a essayé de le faire en danger rien
comme jeremy gabriel il l'a même invité
à venir avec lui sur scène
mais si tout à fait louable sauf que
tout ce que tu veux dire mais comment
l'autre leur soif vous le savez ça le
nombre de fois au dessus par la table on
doute on exclut quelque chose tu veux
dire quelque chose
l à comprends exactement ce que tu fais
ça finit par dévotion pour ce sport
[Rires]
c'est un peu la même chose sauf que tu
fais nos relations à un à un des os x 8
millions comment tu peux contrôler ton
message à manille quand ils contrôlent
petit gars on se calme suppose que je
voulais dire point final
on revient à 0 pt quand tu parles du
second degré de raison de le dire parce
qu'ils en ont un qui quand les gens le
comprennent pas le tsigane seul dont on
va laisser tomber tes yvon deschamps
quand il est arrivé à m'amener au
saguenay après la catastrophe l'aide du
déluge et arrivant à 98 depuis dix ans
entre costa seco table passé le 31 en
région les gens ont pouffé de rire sans
repos et et yvon deschamps les gens
l'auraient détester parce que you so
aussi c'est quand on dit qu'est ce que
tu peux dire avec le personnage que tu
incarnes et le personnage qu'incarne
mike ward peut aller
ce qu'annonce un certain niveau beaucoup
plus loin que les autres sauf que tu
peux pas te dire que ça du point de vue
légal c'est dans la constitution c'est
dans la charte des droits et libertés
pitot comme des limites fait que les
gens qui disent moi ma liberté
d'expression je dis ce que je veux dude
nom à l'école avait eu le droit de eyl
lui il est bien non tu avais pas le
droit de dire ça puis quand tu as des
enfants
moi j'ai deux enfants puis thilleman et
ma fille me dit ah est lui papa il est
très gros il est pas beau jeu rebelles
ont dit au sort on peut pas s'attaquer
au physique des gens ma fille de 8 ans
c'est ce que j'essaie de lui inculquer
comme valable c'est tout ce qu'on s'est
fait dire
puis le temps que quelqu'un qu'une
position publiques qui peuvent
s'attaquer que si on comprend pas le
second degré ou physique de quelqu'un tu
dis c'est au tce mais je comprends que
son intention puis de son contexte et
précis simplement c'est que les faits
qui a apprécié de tous que ça eu sur
l'expansion bien peut-être qu'il
faudrait dix fermes déflagration pour
dire bien tout va bien personne ne veut
de mal à personne parce que je pense pas
que michael veut du mal
persuadés que non non on pille même puis
et et vice versa c'est que les deux cas
en fait les fans ou les supporteurs des
deux cas sont beaucoup plus intense que
les principaux intéressés mais c'est
difficile en même temps c'est la
position que j'essaie d'avoir avec vous
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est je peux
quand même quoi faut qu'il continue à
faire de l'humour pis sans que son
inutilité et phi phi mais jérémy gabriel
a été blessé faut qu'ils s'entendent
pied un moment d'anima quoi il aurait
tout simplement pu dire lagarde 7 jours
que j'ai fait pour le moment attaquer
quelqu'un d' attaquer au bronzage de
pick up et pis ça va être ça m'est
accordée comme tu dis mais c'est juste
que déjà l'information quantique hantise
quand on utilise le mot sata qui s'est
déjà très connaître raison fort
heureusement deux raisons est ce que
c'est vraiment est ce que c'était
vraiment une attaque non je leur formule
et à raison puisque plutôt si il prend
jérémy gabriel comme un sujet de blagues
on va le dire comme sa sortie c'est plus
sincères mais encore une fois c'est pas
du tout mais ça m'a fait rire aussi
quand j'écoutais les et levier jean
françois mercier careep qui parlait de
gad elmaleh qui avait volé des jobs il
dit je pourrais en citer plusieurs au
québec qui volent des jobs ch à ces cons
oui assez riche
non t ça serait une manière aussi de
s'attaquer on l'avait fait quand il y
avait tout le débat sur qui volent des
jo kaki 20 grands dossiers dans la
presse où tu voyais voici la job de
l'humoriste britannique voici ce qu'en
dit telle personne est un truc c'était
beaucoup fait attaquer 7 et françois
massicotte qui disent qu'on disait
qu'ils volaient des jo qu'à gauche à
droite mike loin de là dessus a été
parfait parce que lui justement et
disait gad c'est le plus grand voleur
qui existe et comique copie en faisant
justement qu'ils vont utiliser ça il
s'est servi de mike ward justement pour
dire nos humoristes français c'est les
plus grands plagiat qui a jamais eu
donc c'est ça fait partie d'une démarche
pis pour ceux que la démarche de mac
oyedepo légitime liszt lpi faut qu'ils
se maintiennent en revanche est ce qu'on
est allé trop loin je pense que oui puis
je pense que beaucoup de gens qui
pensent qu' il ya une dérive en ce
moment je retire ce que je viens de
faire parce que je sais pas du tout ce
que pensent les gens
mais pour revenir l'arrière quelque
chose qu'on a dit un petit peu plus tôt
quatre pas l'idée du livre je dise lui
si c'est drôle parce qu'elle est
justement on t'as l'air que en fait j'ai
comme l'impression que le débat dans
l'espace public au québec
ça commence à lever avec les réseaux
sociaux ce phénomène qui nous vaut
pileux les gens capote ppi ont jamais
vécu ce pilot les gens qui à la censure
je me fais censure ips ips eu des
exemples slave
peu importe la position qu'on est là
dessus est ce qu'on peut appeler ça de
la saur sur rance pow l'ascension ce
poisson semble la censure si une
autorité au gouvernement un roi quoi que
ce soit qui dit toi tu peux pas dire ce
tout peut dire ce que c'est pas ça ça
vienne en bourse à vis du peuple ça
vienne en dessous t il ya eu un débat il
ya eu justement c'est comme le je
m'exprime
on me répond au tessin les centurions
ont pu organiser non ce
maintenant j
la plateforme ôta répond on peut avoir
un débat autres et puis celui qui a
raison ou tort aux yeux que les
arguments les plus forts faux ben on
laisse pas triomphé ben c'est
intéressant comme nation parce que tu
voyais beaucoup d'études qui sont faites
du point de vue sociologique pour savoir
qu'est ce que le débat est ce que le
débat est utile
puis j'en ai eu beaucoup de débats avec
plusieurs de mes opposants
puisque je lisais du point de vue
sociologique c'est que dans un débat tu
jamais convaincre la personne le seul
intérêt d'un débat c'est que les mauvais
argument trop mais celui qui est bien
ancrée en toi celui qui te définis il
peut pas s'opposer si j'ai eu des grands
débats avec mathieu bock côté notamment
du point de vue de l'histoire de la
représentation de l'histoire puis on est
même allé manger une couple de fois
ensemble on n'est pas d'accord sur bd à
faire mais je ne le déteste pas pâti us
que c'est quelqu'un avec qui tu aimes
d'abattre moi j'aime ça mais en fait
mathieu on a cette manière très
française de débattre c'est à dire c'est
que tu le clash et mais je pense pas que
ça sert beaucoup lui très français dans
sa demeure complètement puis d'ailleurs
c'est que c'est la petite formule qui va
faire une belle attaque ou encore ce
qu'on appelle le tunnel interprétatif le
tunnel c'est que je pogne je t'amène
avec moi pendant 3 minutes puis tu sais
pas où est ce que je vais mais je parle
pendant trois ans dit fais tu fais comme
je peux pas intervenir chez même pas où
il s'en va et deborah je fais comme
chrysler comment il est arrivé là
écoutez ça où l'argument d'autorité
c'est comme moi je suis et j'ai étudié
donc toi tu connais rien mais tu es
c'est l'argument alors c'est une
position rhétorique et la rhétorique
pour la rhétorique qui se pose c'est
intéressant
j'aime beaucoup et yoni des émissions
que j'aime beaucoup à radio canada c'est
c'est fou avec serge bouchard piaf et
les plots ou non ce super puis dans
cette émission les dix on prend une
question qui nous autres on va pas
essayer de répondre nécessairement mais
on va tourner autour
quand tourne autour on peut être trouver
des éléments de réponse mais jamais on
va essayer de dire voici ce que vous
devez penser voici ce qu'il faut à être
absolument pour comprendre ce que c'est
que la jalousie ce que celles en huit
ils prennent un thème puis tourne auto
[ __ ] et ça fait juste du bien et puis à
chaque fois que si vous le connaissez
pas serge bouchard allez allez le voir
ont l'impression que le cerveau respect
si jamais une oppression sait jamais une
violence est toujours un appel m
le recul sur les choses c'est qu'il faut
pas s'enflammer ou non sur quoi que ce
soit il déteste les français serge des
dix jeux impôts j'aime la culture mais
n'a pas varié puis il ya une manière
très 6
il m'avait demandé il ya quelques années
justement au magazine new montréal de
définir celui qui serait mon ma figure
du thé l'apce bessou choisi serge puis
on avait parlé pendant longtemps
puis serge de magnate retrait québécois
d'aborder les hippies d'aborder n'ont
pas de confrontation ni le débat mais un
échange
c'est ça qui est bon c'est ce qu'on fait
ici t il ya des affaires avec lesquelles
je n'étais pas d'accord quand je les dis
mais jamais tu me dire quand liste est
un cave duo moi je nuancerais tel
affable le jeu fait homme est
intéressant ce que tu dis c'est ce qu'on
trouve du talent c'est tout l'intérêt
qu'on peut avoir au québec contrairement
à la france où il se clashent
s'engueulent chacun votre son bord qui
vont encore plus de leur bord ce que
peut avoir tendance à faire mathieu pis
c'est une des critiques qu'on peut faire
à certains de ses opposants
c'est que plus il critique plus en vue
de l'autre bord pis moi il ya
d'ouverture alors qu'on est capables de
se parler et on est capable de s'ouvrir
l'un et l'autre puis on n'a pas les
mêmes idées
ce que rec 6 mais quand je m'attaque
attendez je m'attaque pas toi toi comme
individu s'en prend plaisir d'aller
manger un steak prendre un verre de vin
avec toi mais on peut ne pas être
d'accord et avancer tranquillement et
c'est pour ça je trouve que serge
bouchard le fait magnifiquement bien
motivé je mettrai des à des cours avec
serge bouchard ou aux étudiants de
seconde à pour leur montrer voici
comment on peut raconter l'histoire que
ce soit captivant pitt est la figure du
vieux qui te raconter boucar diouf et sa
carrière en disant mon cas mon grand
père disait mais le grand pas il a dit à
radio can
il suffit de l'écouter toutes les
semaines que vous avez cette espèce de
d'ouverture c'est comme non seulement tu
couches moins content
j'aime pas c'est que ces expressions
lomé mais ton esprit sait où va donc
comme l'impression que des couleurs que
tu voyais pas tout d'un coup puis le
jugement rapide que tu avais sur un
sujet de ce fait comme au donc il faut
que je réfléchisse un peu plus le spi
plus réfléchi plus
c'est comme une démarche socratique dans
ce que je sais c'est que je ne sais rien
puis comme je ne sais rien je vais me
documenter je vais aller en chercher
davantage puis ça c'est très noble com
com comme attitude
ces gars-là est extraordinaire puis
c'est drôle parce que lui ça nous ont
parlé des degrés à sion vulgarisation
scientifique puis lui ce n'est un de
première classe puis les gens s'en
rendent même pas de temps qu'on recense
que on le perçoit comme un hymne aux
risques en europe comme un homme de de
télévision aux deux t2 mais c'est un
scientifique tente ça reste un bon
scientifique tpiy justement vu qui
mélange humour poésie histoire et
sciences sa porte tellement bien
d'autres et il y en a un autre mois que
j'aime beaucoup c'est david goudreault
que vous connaissez peut-être qui tint
un romancier qui fait aussi des
spectacles pour jouer avec les mots une
forme de slam ya au théâtre outremont je
pense au mois de janvier si vous avez
l'occasion allez le voir aller lire ses
livres d'un gars qui jouent
magnifiquement bien avec les mots métier
et aussi qu'on est dans un moment au
québec où une renaissance de la poésie
qui est impressionnant c'est
impressionnant de pardon une renaissance
de la littérature autochtone on est
vraiment choyés du point de vue culturel
au québec pour peu qu'on s'y intéresse
pour peu qu'on comprenne à quel point
une richesse donc allez-y ça vaut
vraiment la peine
puis documentez-vous ben en fait le
problème justement cette comme on disait
tout à l'heure c'est que l'algorithme
qui est celui de nos réseaux sociaux
nous empêche de voir ce nom peu le
configurer aussi votre facebook et
autres moi par exemple les premières
choses que je vois quand j'ouvre mon
facebook c'est france culture donc je
vois par exemple un petit vidéo de deux
minutes sur l'histoire du doigt
d'honneur donc comment ça se fait qu'on
fait un finger d'où ça vient et cetera
l'histoire de la chanson bella ciao en
italie c'est des tapas des tapas de
contenus j'aime beaucoup cette notion le
pont serait capable de le faire c'est
des petites choses faciles ou est-ce que
tu ne t'y un coût de ce fait ces dons
mais cool j'en veux plus c'est ça tout
la job
on se donne pas la peine de pharming
serment un tri nécessaires nous c'est
fou comme les réseaux sociaux c'est un
miroir dans le fond c'est de me wade est
ce qu'on est des ce qu'on consomme puis
si on veut changer
c'est comme à
comment se changent jamais où ça change
dans le miroir qu'on va se changer
comment ce que je sais si tu es tu laves
le miroir problèmes aux défenseurs de
notre miroir changeant de miroir qu'on
va changer maintenant tout à fait raison
puis c'est notre rapport aux réseaux
sociaux y en a beaucoup qui les
critiquent mais son la fête soit une
gens sont ils refusent
puis le gérer ça veut dire avoir une
hygiène justement numérique efficace
puis faire attention à part regarder
juste de la marde
c'est comme la nourriture se consomme du
mcdo pendant un mois c'est comme dans
super size me tu vas avoir des problèmes
cardiaques
sauf que là les problèmes cardiaques ça
va être une autre file du cerveau puisse
voter du mauvais bon sens donc c'est
qu'à un moment donné quand tu fais des
raccourcis trop facile de conquest ion
complexe celle opté dans marde
quant à une question ultra compliqué qui
pensent avoir la réponse en deux minutes
le même quatre périodes quand tu fais
une chronique dans le journal de
montréal est il plus lui qui s'appelle
tu appelles richard c'est que ça va mal
si une chose moi je veux que les gens
retiennent de ce que je fais c'est que
non seulement ils se disent je veux en
savoir plus mais en j'avais pas vu saône
mind puis c'est ce que je veux comme
sentiment moi quand je regarde quelque
chose si c'est quelque chose de trop
convenu de trop facile du fait comme on
aime toutes les femmes des avengers qui
et c'est tout le fun les super héros
sauve qu'à un moment donné tu en as
envie d'avoir un film comme incendies de
wajdi mouawad
tu as envie de voir une pièce de théâtre
temps à vie dit avant de rentrer vous
parlez de gmi d'euros tant vite sauté
j'ai mis deux rôles de christine
beaulieu j'ai capoté meilleur rien là
dedans qui disposait marché pour pitcher
son et producteur rodney et tu fous tout
à créer un show de cinq heures où est ce
qu'une fille parle pas et mal arranger
ça marchera pas c'est un succès story
c'est la preuve qu est-ce qui est là
dedans des soucis du contenu pur fait
comment ça se fait qu'on n'est pas
capable de le faire + m'ont dit c'est le
pen c'est que malgré j'aime hydro il y
en a qui vont dire oui mais ça c'est
vraiment
c'est arrivé une fois ça arrivera plus
on va leur redonner ce qu'ils aiment
un stand un micro point final compenser
la preuve qu'il ya un appétit pour ce
c'est la preuve que quand tu qui a quand
tu veux passer de l'information ou juste
traiter d'un sujet d'un dossier mais de
manière rigoureuse mais tulameen d'une
façon qui digest qui est drôle qui pète
avec coeur
ben ça va marcher mais oui mais on
écoute quand tu regardes les productions
québécoises pour peu qu'on a travaillé
en télé en radio c'est et 15 ans qu'on
arrive à faire avec les moyens on a du
calibre international qui quand on
regarde la télé les téléromans français
leur plastique c'est pas bon ça n'a pas
de bon sens comment c'est pas bon
puisqu'on arrive à faire nous ici avec
l'argent qu'on a c'est impressionnant
avec imagine tu prends ses moyens de
production la tulle ajoute avec du
contenu piano du contenu this que fait
le jeu pharma chien c'est hallucinant
vie mais sans ramasse la cochonnerie ou
scellier le champion du monde je préfère
mille fois faire valoir un olivier
bernard que un truc de divertissement
pour le plaisir ou otis en mes chances
d'encore un autre show d'humour à la
télé de radio can c'est là ils sont en
train de mettre les cartes blanches à
radio can
c'est comme vous êtes sûr que le
vendredi soir il n'y a pas autre chose
qu'on pourrait mettre dans une heure de
grande écoute qui intéresserait les gens
mais plus encore qui les rendraient
peut-être moins content du populisme lui
mlle mourant con quoi il y en a certains
mais t on est capable d'avoir des trucs
qui sont super bien fait
j'avais participé à une télé sert à
télé-québec s'appelait québec avec un
cas sur l'histoire du québec était
animée par noémie merci c'était deux
fois 15 minutes
un thème histoire de la forêt l'histoire
de l'électricité l'histoire de la mode
et c'est sur le québec
c'est super bien fait puissants marchés
sauf qu'ils se sont dit bobby locke et
c'est bon on passe à autre chose
c'est comme si tout d'un coup c'est se
sont dit on a fait notre part pour soit
maintenant au revient la programmation
naturel
des fois de télé fois les gens savent
pas quelque chose qui intéresse avant de
russie selon ses mots je ne savais pas
grand intérêt pour la science avant
d'écouter cosmos à venir de grosses
têtes
on comprend plus je trouve intéressant
puis l'homme cheveux fihri foot et j'ai
juste poursuivi cette quête de
connaissances scientifiques t mais il a
fallu que j'aille un déclic tant pis si
tu leur présente jamais parce que tu dis
est ce parce que les gens aiment se
passe et que j'en consomme
ils sauront jamais qu'ils ont intérêt à
6 c'est que c'est intéressant ce que tu
dis parce que si on se penche à l'école
j'aimais pas soif et que j'aimerai passe
en général
ouais mais peut-être quand le pot bien
présentes étaient prêts à cette époque
les gens qui dit j'aime pas le théâtre
c'est comme non qu'est ce t'as vu c'est
comme si tu vu les uns brou la jetant un
type de théâtre seul perdre de vue ses
comptes a forcé à les voir une pièce
classique voir hamlet à ya pas longtemps
jeté les voir un show c'était au diamant
québec c'est les sept branches de la
rivière autant ces hausses étant ça dure
c'est à ça a été la pièce la plus courte
de ma vie le feeling que c'est une
expérience ils vont leur prendre
probablement webster cours et là dessus
si vous êtes cet art vous allez capoté
c'est les cinq heures de christine
beaulieu on a l'impression que c'est
court mais il cette branche là c'est
débile c'est et ça se passe à hiroshima
avec la pompe que tout un rapport aussi
avec les individus qui a semé le théâtre
qu'on fait ici là c'est impressionnant
de beauté de vérité d'authenticité
c'est un coup dans le coeur qui méritent
d'être vécues puis même si vous dites
j'en ai vu une c'est pas bon non rien vu
prenez le temps puis surtout c'est que
des prix en ce moment où est ce qu'on
peut avoir des billets pas trop cher à
gauche à droite puis un titre de tennis
du monde qui sont nm - un peu - métier
il y en a qui sont duceppe prenez là
tant pis ça vous abonner puis même des
choses musique des shows de danse
mettez vous en contact morial ya une
richesse infinie artistiques culturelles
des shows à tous les hordes peut les
voir quelque chose même même à québec au
niveau du théâtre qui y sont bien elles
diamant qui a quand même
ajoutez à l'oeuvre théâtrale écouteurs
robert lepage qui quand même des chaude
lutte dans son thé ses fous complet là
c'est quand même impressionnant mais bon
ça on parle d'autre chose
j'ai deux questions pour toi change a
plus de sujet qu'est ce que tu penses du
fait de revisiter re visionner
l'histoire selon un peu nos murs où nos
valeurs actuelles mais c'est pas de
l'histoire ça c'est de la mémoire c'est
quand on parle beaucoup de amherst
puis john mcdonough on se dit c'est des
gens qui ont pressé c'est des gens qui
ont tué c'est des gens qui seront rendus
coupables de meurtres à grande échelle
donc il faut les enlever de l'espace
public fine la différence entre histoire
puis la mémoire l'histoire d'une
démarche scientifique qui vise à mettre
au jour les événements du passé point
finances et de la rationalité
la mémoire c'est dans l'émotion c'est
dans la construction d'une identité
collective donc on va chercher des
modèles qui répondent à cette identité
là donc aujourd'hui par exemple on est
dans une une ouverture beaucoup plus
grande envers les peuples autochtones
qui on se rend compte que par exemple
joey logano qui a organisé ce que
plusieurs considèrent un génocide dans
les prairies se dit ce gars là il ne
peut pas être considéré comme un héros
national
donc on le tance y en a qui vont dire
c'est de la javellisation d'histoire non
c'est de la mémoire ce pas la même
affaire johnny mais quand elle va
toujours être dans les livres d'histoire
en revanche on va dire il le fait aussi
çà çà çà çà çà pour dire que l'histoire
n'est ni blanche ni noire
c'est toujours une zone grise comme on
disait tout à l'heure fake moi j'ai
aucun problème avec ça en revanche il
faut pas considérer que la mémoire c'est
l'histoire faut pas considérer que les
lieux communs qu'on se raconte et le
fait de dire voici ce qu'on doit honorer
et tout le reste est de la marde non
l'on tombe dans un roman le roman
national dont on parlait tout à l'heure
puis est ce que le danger de tout ça
peut pas devenir que finalement en
commentant devant les stations nous
enlève tout parce que finalement
personne il personne qui est blanc sur
blanc
non mon métier c'est parce que il n'ya
jamais personne qui est blanc sur de
l'enceinte a raison de le dire en
revanche c'est qd on a envie de mettre
de l'avant une action politique ou une
réalité ti les billets de banque le 10 $
avec viola desmond qu'on a mis dessus la
11è bain les noirs ayant non au québec
depuis un méchant bout tant pis même au
canada puis sont absolument pour présent
c'est la représentation de la diversité
là au québec on a l'impression qu'on
était tout blanc francophones
catholiques c'est pauvre et puis les
immigrants c'est pas neuf dans
l'histoire du québec
juste pour vous donner une idée à la fin
du 19e siècle montréal était la deuxième
ville juive
après new york en amérique c'est vous
dire
les juifs ont constitué un peuple et une
identité extrêmement fortes d'autant
plus que quand on regarde les plats
typiquement real est celle explique
mythe le bergen les épices à steak de
montréal trois éléments de la culture
juive avec un moment donné il faut
l'intégrer
on peut pas considérer que tout est
blanc blanc blanc sauf que c'est ta
question étant que est-ce qu'on doit
laisser de côté ces éléments là je pense
port je pense que de toute façon ils
vont toujours être dans les livres
d'histoire quoi qu'on fasse et quoi
qu'on dise
puis parce que juste ce que vous avez
écouté l'adisq oui avec l'ouverture avec
le hip hop puis exact mais j'ai juste
pensé à ça parce qu'on parlait de 2
comment maintenant on revisite la
culture autochtone québec
en en parlant de plus en plus qu'à
florent vollant voit gagner c'est
toujours brillé montée et parlait
beaucoup dans sa langue natale puis
ensuite il ya 10 soyez sans crainte nous
venons un ami j'ai tellement à trouver
ceux du génie de faire inquiéter vous
pondre l'apprendre pauvre place
conviendra pas rentrer dans
à votre place en europe à vous avez vous
assez difficile pour les québécois de
ramener sain parce que c'est toute
l'histoire du québec est basé sur une
des très fortes c'est à dire les anglais
nous ont pressés - les anglais nous ont
mis de côté les anglais nous ont
empêchés on peut pas devenir un pays
parce qu'ils l'ont pas voulu on n'a pas
pu parler notre langue parce qu'ils
n'ont pas voulu nous sommes un peuple
oppressé donc on se dit comment un
peuple oppressé comme l'avoir pressé d'y
aller c'est une manière de penser les
choses très complexe pour les québécois
ça fait des années même des générations
qu'on nous dit que nous sommes après
c'est plus on vous dit vous êtes des
oppresseurs vous nous avez aux pressions
avant tout plutôt pauvre a passé le
pauvre est fait ouais ouais
peut-être ma job d'arrivée c'est dire la
loi sur les indiens la fin du 19e siècle
qui disait que la les indiens donc les
premières nations n'était pas des
personnes morales et qu'elle n'existait
pas hésité même inférieur aux femmes
mais ça c'est une représentation qui
quand même qui existe encore aujourd'hui
quitté la présence autochtone il était
inférieur
les fans n'avaient pas le droit d'avoir
un compte de banque avant les années 50
il fallait que leurs hommes coeur marie
singh pour l affecter notre société
québécoise compense très avancé c'est le
fruit de longues luttes et si tu me
disais tout à l'heure à quoi ça sert
d'étudier l'histoire c'est d'être
conscient que nous sommes le produit de
tout un ensemble de lutte et qu'il faut
respecter les gens
justement qui se sont battus pour avoir
ce qu'on appelle la liberté d'expression
qui hélas non dont je dirai qui tu es
elle avait une limite presque illimitées
là bas c'est parce qu'il ya des gens qui
sont arrivés qui était avant nous et qui
se sont battus pour ça on peut être
d'accord ou pas d'accord c'est sûr que
c'est jamais parfait mais il faut quand
même avoir une certaine reconnaissance
envers eux mais pour reconnaître aussi
qu'il ya des pages qui ne nous honore
pas ou qui n'honore pas nos enfants
et ça c'est pas une attaque envers nous
c'est pas parce que vous aviez un grand
père qui a oppressé des autochtones que
ça faites vous une moins bonne personne
au contraire ça fait de vous quelqu'un
qui doit être plus conscients de la
réalité actuelle est pas nécessairement
de réparer mais au moins d'avoir une
conscience citoyenne par rapport à des
jeux là c'est ça de gagné le traitement
qu'il réserve aux autochtones au québec
pour vrai quand je pense à sam des
crises des crises vraiment je trouve ça
absolument horrible pdg de l'ammoniac tv
revient quand on compare le débit
podcast damanaki l'histoire est racontée
je suis pro jacques article on dirait
qu'ils ont découvert les américains l
année on ne rit découvert tabarnak y
avait eu 10 mois et le madrier découvre
à aller plus loin si je regarde du côté
de la rivière des outaouais tous les
livres d'histoire en ontario on va dire
que celui qui a découvert le canada
c'est au dessus de ce que ce mot jon
kabat en 14 197 je me souviens bien
tandis qu'au canada c'est jacques
cartier avec 1 134 donc qu'à but qui est
un britannique et quartier qui est un
français
sauf que les premières nations font
comme parce qu'on était le piment éviter
les vikings sont venus si les basques
sont venus ici
mais j'aime pas ça la notion de
découvrir j'aime posture la notion de
inventé c'est comme si moi qui ai pas
savoir tout le monde juste juste les
faits d un mélange de saintes et de dire
on est découvert ce qui suit pas on chez
hbo je peux le quartier jeudi on est un
melting-pot de prendre fin oui moi je
suis plus le descendant de jacques
arctique d'autres mais aujourd'hui
québec c'est comme un paon d'or quartier
compte la question qui pose puis
l'interrogation qui est la tienne c'est
le coeur même de toutes les
représentations mémorielle c'est le haut
ou le nous le problème c'est quand tu
dis nous tue exclu texan les autres
défini contre quelqu'un puis les
québécois ont cédé fini contre les
britanniques contre les autochtones mais
leur toute la question de se dire est ce
que le nous ne pourrait pas avoir des
frontières plus large et moins fermé
c'est toute la question qu'on pose
actuellement c'est toute l'opposition
qui a avec certains chroniqueurs de
droite qui disent non le nous ces
francophones blanc catholique comme mais
ça n'a jamais été son ya jamais eu jeu
des blancs francophones catholiques au
québec arrêtez de penser ça c'est
peut-être et est ce que vous considérez
comme le coeur de la nation
c'est quand j'ai leproux dans son
dernier livre est dit les historiens
professionnels ne s'intéressent pas la
nation c'est quoi fois absolument
s'intéresser à la nation pour être un
bon historien du fait mais vous mettez
la charrue devant les boeufs en pensant
ce mythe est une construction militante
et nous reproche beaucoup de notre bord
en disant vous ce que vous faites c'est
du militantisme
si vous voulez mais c'est parce qu'on
essaie de regarder le large spectre de
la complexité de l'histoire parce que
l'histoire n'est ni blanche ni noire
c'est un ensemble de gens qui ont essayé
de faire au mieux avec les éléments qui
leur était donnée lieu du bon vieux du
mauvais est ce que ge a jugé non j'ai à
comprendre essayer de comprendre puis
plus tu vends savoir sur l'histoire
- tu veux juger plus tu vas comprendre
c'est ton histoire de des poils
justement le défi qui se laissent
pousser le poil en arc c'est dégueulasse
ça me révolte je trouve ça beau sexy
mais tu te rends compte que toi-même
décoder socialement
puis on te renforcer l'image qu'une
femme ça doit être doux tous les procès
contre la grossophobie on dit bon ben la
femme dwight minds parce que la femme
mannequin
il ya tout un ensemble de formes
féminines qui existe et dans l'histoire
ça a évolué aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
dit être beau mais est-ce qu'on doit
absolument se limiter à la fille qui a
pas mangé depuis deux jours
t on n'est pas obligé si on on peut
ouvrir le large spectre sans que ce soit
discriminatoire ou que ce soit est une
attaque envers les valeurs de quelqu'un
c'est la grande difficulté qu'il annonce
qui est la nôtre actuellement d'accepter
la différence de l'autre mais d'accepter
le point de vue de l'autre en disant
voici le mien voix s'il tient on peut
coexister et ça se fait la coexistence
pacifique peut exister pitch aussi qu'au
québec on est tellement bon avec ça on
aime tellement le consensus
on aime tellement passera sans délai
tout est là pour qu'on soit capable de
gérer nos chaussées pondent exportant
les clashs à la française qu'on va
réussir
c'est en prenant un peu comme ce qu'on
disait avec serge bouchard halle de
cette capacité à ouvrir et à être plus
accuser une question pour toi
justement qu'un conte repenser
l'histoire différemment qu'on se raconte
à qui fera t elle figure et elle figure
était problématique ou telle façon de
faire à l'époque outils quand on dit les
moeurs changent de ton par l'état
certaine tantôt plus quand on les
jugeait nos yeux d'aujourd'hui on se
devait voyons donc c'est que c'était un
type d'humour quoi que ce soit d'une
autre époque
d'après toi je te sors peut-être de ton
un rien plus possible pour vous parler
de la société d'aujourd'hui mais qu'est
ce que tu penses qu'ils sont nos moeurs
nos agissements d'aujourd'hui que dans
vingt 20 ans 30 ans ont regardé pour
fois oui ça ça n'a pas de bon sens qui
se passe une grosse question déjà notre
rapport à la voiture
notre rapport à la consommation notre
rapport au ciel à l'environnement on va
se dire comment ça se fait qu'ils ont
laissé un gouvernement détruire la
planète volontairement alors que tout le
monde le savait ça je pense que ça va
être le grand problème que nous avons
sur toi notre rapport à la bien oui
notre rapport à
à l'entraînement qu'on fait des animaux
moi j'essaie d'être végétarien depuis un
petit bout de temps mais la baisse parce
que tout le monde me dit c'est un jour à
la fois j'ai vu un documentaire sur
netflix qui m'a un peu traumatisé mais
dans le bon sens du terme vous l'avez
peut-être vu de game challenge très
excitant de penser à toi pour plein
d'affaires c'est excellent c'est pas le
documentaire le plus rigoureux ainsi toi
pardon mais pour pleine affaire c'est
super intéressant parce que c'est comme
tout et n'importe quel point principal
puis éventuellement on en parlait avec
emi droit puis on en parle beaucoup dans
notre cas puisque moi je suis vegan
activistes entre guillemets c'est
quelque chose qui m'habite beaucoup mais
pour l'environnement on n'aura pas le
choix mais tu vu la capsule que j'ai
fait sur l'histoire du végétarisme non
je n'ai pas vu avec jean philippe siat
héros garage solidaire de toute
l'histoire du végétarisme pour dire rien
9 je vais jouer absolument tic et ancien
pardon on promouvait sus ces questions
justement dans de game center
tantôt j'ai eu un flash de ce moment le
nom dans le documentaire wes que cas
qu'on parlait de l'épilation tout à
l'heure
4 comprend la naissance d'une croyance
qu'on aujourd'hui manger de la viande de
l'iphone il expliqué ils ressortent la
première wac se l'était dit que la
viande est capable laden rendait lui 130
salles a été automatiquement démonter
par d'autres scientifiques de l'époque
mais son étude à lui est resté c'est
devenu comme quelque chose qu'on a qu'on
cultive encore aujourd'hui des légendes
comme luis et qui mange je sais pas
combien de fois par jour si c'est ford
en mai mais pour répondre à des
questions j'ai trouvé ça excellent comme
comme documentaire comme jeudi il ya
plein de trucs scientifiques qui ont été
démontés puis je pense pas que c'est le
point principal du truc
je pense que le point c'est de montrer
que pour tout le monde qui souhaitent
diminuer sa consommation de viande c'est
tout à fait possible de rester
extrêmement efficace athlétique de
performer aux eaux extrêmement
performant en fait pour être porteuses
mais j'avoue que les recettes qui donne
à voir sur le site internet
oh non c'est pas s'accrocher bord mais
il ya des très bons livres de recettes
par exemple côté cuisine vegan l'on peut
on a pas d'offre non à l'islam n'est pas
placé sur place c'est vrai ma blonde on
a écrit ce livre mais jean-philippe
aussi avait quitté travailler c'est un
excellent chef puis éventuellement la
parenthèse véganisme je pense que dans
dix ou vingt ans vous regardez le
traitement qu'on fait des animaux et
dont vous trouvé ça complètement
complètement puis pour revenir à notre
bon vieil ami richard martineau qui est
fait un article la semaine passée qui
disait cru mais le sully vegans qui
veulent y en aura plus de 28 ans n'aura
plus de cochons fait qu'ils vont
peut-être plus de sous ben moi je
préfère qu'il y ait plus de vaches mille
cochons que qu'on continue à l'émetteur
à les mettre en vie pour les torturer
pendant six mois puis les tués avaient
pu j'ai entendu un extrait audio
d'après moi c'est un sport d'équipé
radio pi ca soit encore jeune la deviner
qui est qui qui sortait s'extrait de
rédiger les animaux d'élevage le on a un
deal avec eux c'est parce qu'elle si on
les mange plus le sopi dans pour se
promener partout l'heure sur sainte
catherine une vaste machine sondage sur
sainte-catherine dit reconnaître votre
espèce va perdurer
on va s'occuper de vous autres prend
soin de vous autres mais on vous mangez
ce seul dirk son argumentaire saison le
décortiquer pour y répondre mais ccc
d'un magnétisme grave si les symptômes
justement tu ne peux pas avoir une
opinion informer sur tous nos élus se
prononcent à chaque jour sur quelque
chose en moi y ait plein de choses sur
lesquelles je n'accepte pas de parler
même des domaines d'histoire comme
maintenant de parler son appli telle
personne louche mais cette semaine je
peux même pas me servir un petit peu ce
qu'on disait par rapport aux humains
restent à leurs pis au québec on aime
beaucoup ont même personne ne parlait de
plaine à faire mathieu bock-côté c'est
un bon exemple
qu'on parlait tout à l'heure aussi
mathieu bock-côté sur plein d'affaires
et pertinents d'autres trucs qui donne
son opinion il n'y a pas aucune
connaissance par rapport à ça d'accord
mais on pense que parce qu'il ya une
rhétorique qui est d'impressionnantes
son point de vue est un prêt est
important surtout ce qu'ils disent est
pas du tout vrai puis d'avoir la d'avoir
ce que toi tu dis avoir donc la capacité
de dire je connais pas sûr je prendrai
pas position
ça nous fera avancer beaucoup plus est
se voit par exemple histoire de slaves
et kanata je n'ai rien dit absolument
pas parce que je me sentais absolument
pas ou fait des recherches autochtones
je ne savais pas comment me positionner
face à ce petit trou le monde dit
quelque chose
même les gens disaient moi je dis que je
ne dis rien n'y faisait des postes là
dessus j'ai fait aucun poste j'ai fait
j'ai lu fait je serais un pid
non mais c'est juste que j'ai dit que
deviendrions oui mais c'est ça c'est
marié qui dit moins quelque chose que de
rien des écoles des gens qui disent bon
moi je dis ça je dis rien c'est comme ça
et regarder ici ou là telle attention
sur tout à fait raison c'est comme les
enfants à quoi je sais pas
oui métier en tout cas ça fait partie
des trucs ou est-ce qu'il faut que tu
acceptes métier on disait tout à l'heure
de se donner un espace de réflexion un
espace c'est pas un type space mais un
espace avec des gens non pas qu'ils te
confronter qui sont pas nécessairement
de ton opinion mais qui vont permettre
d'avancer de voir ta vision des choses
1 et bonn puis 2 de donner le droit de
la changer parce que c'est tout le
problème de notre espace public
quand tu arrives à télé ou à radio
svoboda écoutez je plus d'accord j'ai
changé mon point de vue le produit vendu
avec lui pour offrir ça on t'attend
qu'est-ce que tu sois cassant puis c'est
que soit carrément bien marquer d'un
côté mais mouche pas marqué d'un côté
sur ben des affaires t-il véganisme qui
m'aurait pas posé la question il est 5h
de la maman je mange un lien plus
tranquillement ça évolue est chaud comme
ben oui c'est vrai tendance à devenir un
peu plus
végétarien pour l'instant éventuellement
peut-être vegan mai peux tu dire sur une
fois que dit ouvertement un espace
public que ont tu vas tu es si on enlève
ton rosbif et pierres précieuses du
ballon je suis devenu vegan tu perds une
automatiquement de la crédibilité que tu
veux pas ça avec foot donne l'espace un
de changer d'idée puis deux de pointe et
revenir surtout pas si notre votre
poignet va devoir virer tes
contradictions parce que dieu sait que
si une chose que nous sommes tous ces d
être contradictoires dont la pensée
évolué c'est très bien pu une chance que
c'est ça mais pour charles qui a
peut-être besoin de devenir un peu plus
un être humain à ta question qui est
tantôt peut-être que on va pas garder
toute la journée et peut-être qu'on peut
conclure sur une source
parce que une des vidéos que tu as fait
sa chaîne qui est le plus panier c'est
celle sur les excréments puis en dessous
d'un vidéo où est-ce qu'on parlait
justement en dessous d'un dépôt de cas
ce qu'on a fait ou est ce qu'on parlait
justement de
loxam nécessite élever des animaux les
clients qui a écrit on parle beaucoup de
locaux utilisent pour tous mais on
semble oublier le paraphrase on semble
oublier qu'on chi dans de l'eau potable
qui circule partout puis qu'on un espèce
de réseaux souterrains extrêmement
sophistiqués pour chier pour cacher la
malle pour cacher notre mari lui disait
est ce qu on pourrait commencer sur la
place publique a parlé des toilettes
sèches piché que la gestion des
excréments mettons au moyen âge était
loin d'être optimales avant d'avoir les
écrans vidéo - cissé avant d'avoir
justement tu es un réseau d'aqueduc qui
nous permettait de flasher atwell mais
peut-être qu'éventuellement on va se
dire dans 20 ans va se dire chier dans
l'eau potable
peut-être que c'est pas la chose la plus
intelligente métier je peux si vous
souvenez du film les visiteurs les juste
un film en 96
jean reno qui sont médiévale y arrivent
dans notre époque puis on leur dit bon
ben voilà la salle de bain la vie vous
les mains maison tu vois la toilette
puis commence à se laver les mains dans
la toilette y boivent l'eau de la
toilette
[ __ ] l'autre qui arrive donc de notre
époque libye mais vous êtes con mais
vous êtes qu ils se lavent dans la
cuvette
il n'en revient pas mais tu dis pour
quelqu'un qui connaît pote d'ubs à
l'égard de nos propres belle donc ça
doit être l'eau c'est cette scène là est
traumatisant mais marque bien la
construction sociale t on dit souvent
nous sommes des êtres construit
socialement mais cette construction
sociale à une histoire qui est un des
éléments que j'avais voulu faire dans
les vidéos c'est de la déconstruire pour
dire nous sommes des êtres codé
socialement pions peut se déprogrammer
pour arriver à quelque chose de plus
utile socialement qu'ils soient en
cohérence avec la nature
c'est tout le programme aussi du
végétarien et les végétariens du
véganisme de dire il faut respecter les
cycles naturels de la nature ne pas
aller contre elle parce qu'on est en
train de la détruire pis là dedans tu
rendent justement sur l'altermondialisme
la décroissance la capacité de gérer
notre planète de manière plus efficace
avec tu te rends compte que j'aime
beaucoup cette idée là c'est comme si tu
avais un t-shirt sur toile
soyez juste un fait
puis en tirages sur ce mini film tout le
tee shirt s'est défait avec mon but
c'est souvent trouvé le fils en question
pour le défendre c'est ce que j'avais
essayé de faire avec l'histoire du cacao
j'avais récidiver avec l'histoire du
pipi je suis très très très pipi caca
merci beaucoup d'action complètement
passionnante où s conduit sur youtube la
vidéo la chaîne s'appelle l'histoire
nous le dira vous allez trouver assez
facilement
je pense sinon est-ce que tu eu des
creux n'est qu'à des endroits où est-ce
qu'on peut temps en temps parce que je
persuadé que le monde sont rendus à ce
moment c'est en tout cas ce qu'ils ont
vraiment chat pénélope une fin de
semaine
je prends un sujet d'actualité qui ont
fait l'histoire comme le bientôt ça va
être l'histoire du tatouage est fait
l'histoire d'une carte de crédit
aussi quand on revenait défaite en dix
ans comment ça serai content d'être à ce
point là en partant de la citation de
coluche qui disait le crédit à long
terme c'est que moins tu peux payer plus
tu payes finalement comment ça se fait
que les plus pauvres payent plus que les
riches fait que je revenais sur cette
idée l'on fait quand que bref pis livre
j'ai écrit une série de romans
historiques qui s'appelle l'homme de
l'ombre puis un livre pour enfant qui
s'appelle hier quand j'étais bébé
je pense que c'est super merci